bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouvel épisode de probablement
aujourd'hui j'accueille thani à lui
docteur en biologie moléculaire et
aujourd'hui pas tu vas nous expliquer un
peu plus que tu fais aujourd'hui ce que
je vous assure de sa c2 bonne question
je ne sais pas trop bonjour
effectivement la bâche hui viejo log est
docteur en biologie moléculaire et j'ai
décidé d'arrêter la recherche après ma
thèse pour faire de la médiation
scientifique et dans le cadre de la
médiation scientifique j'ai fait pas mal
de trucs
la première chose que j'ai faite c'est
rester au chômage longtemps ce qui m'a
donné l'occasion de lancer une chaîne
youtube n'est ce pas d'autres je crois
que j'en ai ensuite j'ai trouvé un poste
comme médiatrice donc vraiment j'animais
des ateliers dans un centre d'assurance
j'allais faire des activités en classe
et c'est quelque chose que j'aime
beaucoup donc je continue à faire mais
plus autant qu'avant parce que j'ai
aussi fait pas mal de gestion de projet
j'organisais la venue de chercheurs dans
des lycées gérer des comptes twitter
collaboratif
j'ai travaillé à l'oreca fait qu' un
café à vocation pédagogique qui a ouvert
à toulouse on a eu la chance de recevoir
un certain lesnevienne à un moment où la
ceinture là j'ai créé des ateliers et
maintenant depuis dix jours je travaille
dans une structure où je coordonne le
pôle médiation
je vais faire des ateliers de temps en
temps et je vais travailler sur un
projet secret que je n'ai pas encore le
droit de révéler mais qui promet d'être
très très cool et à côté de ça je monte
ma boîte pour faire de la médiation en
plus parce que tout ça c'est du travail
à temps partiel donc ça passe plein de
temps pour faire d'autres projets à côté
et c'est très chouette
ok du coup fait revenir un peu plus en
arrière côte était intéressé à la
virologie à grande question
la raison pour laquelle j'ai choisi la
virologie à la base c'est que c'était le
domaine de la biologie qui permettait de
toucher à tout en maniant dire que
j'aimais bien la biologie moléculaire
mais je trouvais ça dommage de sliimy
théâtre
il ya une seule échelle est en fait qu
on en fait de la virologie on peut
travailler à l'échelle de la molécule à
l'échelle de la cellule à l'échelle de
l'organisme voire à l'échelle de la
population
c'est quelque chose que je trouvais
vraiment hyper intéressant que ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point c'est
que les virus sont pleins de surprises
et ça pour un chercheur c'est quelque
chose d'hyper intéressant il ya plein de
choses qu'on ne connaît pas par rapport
aux virus il ya plein de choses qu'on
pense comme acquise en biologie et puis
quand on regarde les virus on se rend
compte qu'en fait bas non pas du tout
donc ça a laissé plein de portes
ouvertes à la curiosité et moi en
général je pense que quand on se dirige
vers la recherche et qu'on est curieux
et c'est comme ça que j'ai fini en
pierre au logis ok ça tu as peut-être
est-ce que tu coup tu t'es toujours
dirigé fatah toujours voulu faire de la
recherche
c'était assez naturel ouais ça a
commencé assez tôt et y ait une grosse
crise existentielle comme beaucoup au
lycée ne paniquez pas si vous êtes en
première et vous ne savez pas ce que
vous voulez faire de votre vie
c'est normal j'hésitais entre des trucs
très différente j'hésitais entre
comédienne critique littéraire prof de
matières scientifiques ou chercheurs en
bio donc il y avait un panel est en fait
un jour je suis allée un salon
d'orientation je suis allé voir une
personne du cnrs en disant bonjour si je
vais être enseignant chercheur il faut
faire quoi elle m'a dit il faut aller en
prépa idéalement intégré normale sup et
c'est la voie royale pour un chercheur
en bio gedibois aller hockey et j'ai
fait ça et tout a marché donc fait aller
jusqu'au bout donc tu aurais eu
demandèrent que je lui demandais comment
avoir un prix nobel que tu auras dit et
tu auras fait que j'aurais dû lui
demander comment avoir un poste de
chercheur savons un peu plus et des
joies et des ducs ou ta thèse en
particulier tu es sûr que c'est une
grande question
j'ai travaillé sur quatre projets
différentes pendant ma thèse
mais il y en a qu'un qui a été publié
donc il y en a qu'un dont je peux
vraiment parler parce que le rester
encore un peu dans des cartons en fait
quand j'étais en master j'ai fait ma
thèse dans le même laboratoire que si
j'avais fait mon master 2 l'équipe avait
identifié une protéine capable
d'empêcher l'infection de certaines
cellules par le vih et c'était une
protéine qui était très
étudier du coup il y avait un peu tout à
découvrir sur ce truc là et on s'est
rendu compte que cette protéine n'était
pas exprimé peu en cas d'infection par
le vih mais qu'elle était là un peu tout
le temps dans les cellules ce qui est
assez surprenant parce que c'est pas ce
qui se passe normalement pour les
facteurs antiviraux et du coup mon
projet principal de test a été d'essayer
de comprendre quelle était la fonction
de cette protéine hla en dehors du
contexte de l'infection par le vih
donc en fait j'étais dans un laboratoire
de virologie pour ne pas faire de
virologie
parce que la vie fait souvent ça dans la
recherche et on s'est rendu compte qu'en
fait cette protéine était alors les mots
compliqués c'est un garant de
l'homéostasie cellulaire concrètement ça
veut dire qu'elle est très importante
pour que tout se passe bien dans la
cellule et on s'est rendu compte qu'elle
était perdue dans pas mal de cas de
cancer d'accord mais dehors du cocon
vous détectez une protéine il ya plein
façon de détecter une protéine il ya
plein de techniques expérimentales
différentes souvent ça revient à un
moment ou un autre à utiliser des
anticorps ne veut donc les anticorps
sont des petites molécules sont elles
mêmes des protéines on se mord un peu la
gueule mais bon produite par notre
système immunitaire et qui sont
spécifiques de ce qu'on appelle la
commande dire ça simplement de motifs
moléculaire qu'on va retrouver chez des
pathogènes en gros c'est ce qui nous
permet de détecter les pathogènes quand
on a infecté et c est donc c'est un truc
qui est produit spontanément par notre
organisme est l'organisme d'autres
mammifères notamment en cas d'infection
et donc on produit des anticorps contre
la protéine qui nous intéresse en
injectant tout ou partie de cette
protéine chez des animaux et en
récupérant leurs anticorps souvent ça va
être des sourires des lapins d'être
comme ça
une fois qu'on a récupéré ces anticorps
ou les couples avec une technique de
détection et là il ya plein de
possibilités différentes
des fois c'est l'émission d'une protéine
d'une couleur fluorescente qu'on peut
détecter au microscope des fois ça va
être des trucs qui sont modifiés qui
produisent de la lumière et qu'on peut
détecter avec des plaques
photographiques
l'idée c'est toujours d'avoir un
anticorps spécifiques de la protéine qui
nous intéresse qui va pouvoir se fixer
dessus et ensuite on couple un système
de reconnaissance à l'anticorps en
question ok et quand a commencé ta thèse
il y avait eu il y avait un anticorps
découverts plus alors cette protéine
sapli samhd1 on l'appeler sam
parce que c'est plus pratique et ouais
il y avait déjà des anticorps pour
l'étudier mais ceci dit c'est pas un
truc si évident que ça parce qu'un des
projets que j'ai abandonné au cours de
ma thèse c'est un projet pour lequel on
s'intéresse à une protéine où on n'a
jamais trouvé d'anticorps qui fonctionne
ok j'en avais testant une dizaine qui
étaient vendus dans le commerce sont qui
était censé marché et qu'on n'a jamais
réussi à faire fonctionner avec nos
techniques de détection à nous donc que
c'est pas si évident ça peut encore
aujourd'hui être de temps en temps à un
problème technique du port et ensuite
comment tu as fait pour essayer
d'étudier parce qu'après tu as cherché à
étudier les fonctions de cette protéine
saison ouais 28e bas étudié les
fonctions en général c'est une vaste
question si tu sais pas du tout ce
qu'elle fait et n'a pas la moindre idée
de parts ou regarder ça va quand même
être un peu compliqué en général la
première chose à regarder c'est avec
quoi interagit cette protéine
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on peut faire
assez facilement une purifie une autre
protéine à partir de cellules où elle se
trouve et on a des techniques comme la
spectrométrie de masse ou des choses
comme ça qui permettent de voir avec
quoi elle interagit ça donne déjà une
idée des types d'actions auxquelles elle
peut participer dans la cellule et
ensuite à partir de ça on conçoit des
expériences nous on avait en tête quel
interagissez avec les briques qui
constitue l'adn et les briques séparer à
l'époque on savait pas du tout si c'est
interagissez avec l'adn en tant que tel
et du coup on s'est dit bon si elle
interagit avec ses briques là il ya une
chance pour qu'elle joue un rôle dans la
prolifération cellulaire
parce que la première étape pour qu'une
cellule puis se multiplier c'est qu'il
faut qu'elle copie son adn
donc si on modifie la quantité de
briques qui est présente dans la cellule
on va modifier la façon dont la cellule
peut copier son adn et se multiplier
donc la première chose qu'on a regardé c
est ce que si on enlève notre protéines
ou qu'on en rajoute encore plus que ce
qui a normalement
ça modifie la vitesse de prolifération
de cellules mais la réponse était oui
donc on a continué dans cette voie là et
est-ce que tu coules la protéine donc
sam a plaidé sans dout prénoms des coûts
sam vous connaissez sa séquence d'acides
aminés ou oui oui ça c'était j'ai
commencé ma thèse en 2011
donc on était déjà bien avancé sur les
techniques de séquençage et de trucs
comme ça et en plus on travaille chez
l'homme
chez l'homme le génome humain a déjà été
séquencés c'est pas si vieux vinça une
quinzaine d'années un peu plus nettement
mais tout le génome humain est déjà
séquencés il ya déjà des bases de
données sur internet avec toutes les
séquences de protéines etc
et en plus sa magie 1 était connu comme
lié à une maladie génétique d'accord
assez peu étudiée parce que c'est un
syndrome merveilleux où les nourrissons
meurent très jeune quand la protéine
n'est pas là mais du coup il y avait
déjà eu des études de séquences qui
avaient été faites justement par rapport
à cette maladie génétique la d'accord et
ce qu il sait aussi le au piment puisque
le au piment
ça c'était plus compliqué non on n'avait
pas la structure
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué d'avoir la
structure d'une protéine que d'avoir sa
séquence ce que la technique principal
pour faire ça c'est une technique qui
passe par de la cristallographie et ça
veut dire qu'il faut déjà réussir à
faire des cristaux propre avec la
protéine en question et c'est un peu du
tâtonnement
parce que chaque protéine est différente
donc les conditions optimales sont
différentes
ça coûte super cher c'est très compliqué
à analyser donc quand on a commencé à
travailler dessus on savait pas et en
fait le fait que cette protéine était
identifié comme capable de bloquer
l'infection de certaines cellules par le
vih a déclenché un énorme effort de
recherche dessus et c'était assez
intéressant parce que en parallèle de ma
thèse y avait plein de publication qui
sortait par d'autres équipes avec pas la
structure notamment d'abord juste de
certaines parties puis de la protéine
entière et on s'est rendu compte qu'en
fait elle agissait pas tout seul elle
agissait en se collant à d'autres
protéines comme l on appelle ça des dix
maires quand y en a deux d'être amère
quand sur l'a4 et du coup il y avait
toute une partie de la recherche qui
était d'essayer de comprendre quelle
était la forme active ce que c'était la
preuve
tout seul est-ce que c'était deux
protéines est ce que c'était 4 et tout
ça sera un peu en même temps google
du coup ça beaucoup bougé du côté des
ouais ça a énormément bougé
c'était un peu frustrant parce qu'on
était à ce moment là on pensait en tout
cas il n'y avait pas d'autres
publications sur toute la partie en
dehors du vih tout ce qui était fait été
fait par rapport au vih puisque c'était
contexte de découverte parce que c'est
un domaine où il ya un peu d'argent pour
travailler et parce que c'est un gros
impact en santé publique est le plus
intéressant pour moi ça a été qu à la
fin de ma thèse il commence à y avoir
d'autres publications en lien avec la
fonction de cette protéine et son rôle
dans le cancer et oum hamza quand on
regarde la biblio il ya à peu près les
deux qui s'équilibre ok du coup j'ai un
rôle à la fois sur le vih et sur le
cancer
ouais elle est parfaite cette protéine
rôle plus important que vous croyez au
début c'est ça ouais carrément on
pensait en fait le truc pour remettre un
peu dans le contexte c'est que les gens
qui travaillaient dans le domaine du vih
cherché à identifier cette protéine
depuis des années on savait qu'il y
avait un truc qui avait un truc qui dans
certaines cellules empêcher l'infection
par le vih mais on savait pas de quoi du
coup quand ça a été identifié et tout le
monde était à fond parce que c'était le
mystère enfin résolu et du coup on
allait pouvoir essayer de comprendre
qu'est ce qui se passait exactement est
en fait le fait que cette protéine soit
là tout le temps et pas juste en cas
d'infection c'est vraiment pas commun
pour les facteurs antiviraux parce que
l'organisme a pas d'intérêt à produire
des trucs en continu s'ils servent à
rien donc la plupart des facteurs qui
répondent aux infections soit par un
virus ou par autre chose sont produits
au moment de l'infection quand
l'infection est détectée et le fait
qu'elle soit là tout le temps ça montre
vraiment qu'en fait le rôle est très
important
et alors nous on avait travaillé surtout
dans le contexte du cancer non se rend
compte que savait aussi un rôle sur la
réparation des dommages causés à l'adn
qui est un truc qui se passe en
permanence dans nos cellules parce que
leur adn et agressé tout le temps mais
ouais vraiment on est sur un niveau
d'importance assez élevé c'est ce qu'il
est
et du coup passerelle et quand tu
imagines évoluer les choses à ce qu on
pourrait comprendre suffisamment pour
orchestrer les conséquences de mieux
comprendre cette protéine
il ya des gens qui travaillent dessus en
permanence à chaque fois alors je vais
pas regarder la biblio tous les deux
jours pour être honnête là ça fait un
moment que les mêmes faits mais à chaque
fois que je vais voir il ya quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de nouvelles
publications
le premier impact potentiel de mieux
comprendre c'est le suc et liées à
l'infection par le vih parce que du coup
les cellules dans lesquelles ça me
bloque l'infection c'est des cellules
immunitaires impliqués dans le
déclenchement de la réponse immunitaire
on pense que c'est une des raisons qui
permettent au virus de mieux se cacher
donc si on n'arrive à faire sauter ce
verrou là au moment où on essaie de
mettre en place un vaccin par exemple ça
permettrait que l'organisme repère mieux
le virus et du coup qu'on ait une
meilleure réponse à des vaccins que ça
c'est une des pistes pour le vih lui ce
serait vraiment important de comprendre
ce qui se passe parce que c'est pas
évident d'aller éliminer la protéine
directement dans les cellules du patient
alors que si on comprend comment elle
marche on peut bloquer son action avec
un moyen plus simple mois pour le cancer
y avait un truc qui m'avait hyper
intéressés et que pour le coup j'ai pas
encore revenue dans la biblio c'est que
quand je faisais mes expériences dans
des boîtes en plastique dans mon petit
laboratoire
le fait d'avoir enlevé sam chez
certaines cellules les rangs des
résistantes aux molécules qu'on utilise
en chimiothérapie
on est très éloignée d'un vrai contexte
clinique mais l'idée c'est que si un
patient qui est un cancer n'a plus sam
c'est possible que ça ne serve à rien de
lui donner certains traitements des
corps et ça en terme d'implication c'est
énorme parce que ça peut éviter de
traiter dans le vide avec des gros
effets secondaires juste en regardant si
cette protéine est présente ou pas mais
que ça pour moi c'était le résultat le
plus important de ma thèse est pour
l'instant c'est un truc que j'ai pas
encore trop vieux ressortir et au delà
de ça le fait que sam soit impliqué dans
la réparation des dommages à l'adn
ça veut dire que surveiller cette
protéine ça pourrait j'extrapole
énormément mais ça pourrait aussi
permettre de détecter le moment où les
cellules par temps gris quand c'est un
cancer qui se développe est clair que si
on perd cette protéine là on va perdre
tout un système de
réparation et de surveillance de l'état
de l'adn et du coup ça peut se dégrader
beaucoup plus rapidement ensuite oui ça
peut aussi être une piste de
surveillance pour établir des
diagnostics précoces par exemple ok ok
du goût donc si je comprends bien donc
l'idée c'est qu'on pourrait mieux
diagnostiquer les patients à savoir
quels sont à skis goce a dit ce porte
bien et du coup adapté des traitements
en fonction de cela ouais
potentiellement est ok cool et du coup
tu as bien aimée par le fatah vie de
chercheuse de des doctorantes il ya des
choses que j'ai beaucoup aimée des
choses que je n'ai pas du tout aimé ce
que j'ai arrêté après caen non il ya la
recherche en général c'est un métier qui
est passionnant mais qui est pas
toujours très gratifiant je sais pas si
les gens se rendent compte
alors c'est peut être encore pire en
sciences expérimentales où on dépend de
plein de conditions sur lesquelles on
mettrait de rien mais je sais pas si les
gens se rendent compte du nombre
d'échecs qu'il faut avant de réussir à
faire marcher une expérience et avoir un
résultat
moi j'ai fait des expériences va pour
les camps pour garder une influence de
sam sur la prolifération des cellules
c'était des expériences qui duraient
plusieurs semaines que tous les jours
fallait récupérer les cellules les
comtés et c est quand tu fais un truc
comme ça et qu'il ya une panne de
courant et que l'endroit où sont rangées
t cellules passe de 37 degrés à 35
degrés dans la nuit tu jettes tout et tu
recommences alors que c'est extrêmement
long et 5 utilise beaucoup de temps
beaucoup de matériel etc
et là il ya une panne de courant tant
pis on jette on refait quoi elissalde
les pannes de courant non parce que dans
sécurisé mais mais les petits aléas
expérimentaux ouais ça arrive et au delà
de ça en plus y'a l'erreur humaine le
dialogue on est humain quand on se
retrouve à devoir récupérer 40
échantillons tous les jours pendant
trois semaines des fois on en inversant
ou de quoi c'est dépendant renversant
mais voilà ça arrive à tout le monde
voilà c'est on travaille sur du vivant
donc forcément il ya une grosse part
d'aléatoire c'est très intéressant en
soi parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
trouve des choses à laquelle on
s'attendait pas et qu'on avance
mais il ya aussi une certaine part de
frustration parce que quand on est en
stage c'est surtout quand on est en
stage qu'on s'en rend compte je pense
parce qu'on arrive dans un labo en
disant allez j'ai trois mois pour faire
un truc est en fait en trois mois en
biologie ont fait rien du tout
enfin cindy sa déraison presse marocaine
a arrêté les recherches
non la raison principale pour laquelle
j'ai arrêté la recherche c'est parce que
c'est à peu près impossible d'avoir un
poste dans mon domaine quand je suis
arrivé on a attendu que je sois en tête
pour me le dire c'est un peu tard mais
le jour de la rentrée de mon école
doctorale
on nous a expliqué que sur tous les gens
présents dans la salle lui en aurait 10
% qui ferait de la recherche à terme de
recherche publics et privés confondus
déjà dire que la probabilité de réussite
à la base est pas énorme et au delà de
ça l'âge moyen de recrutement à l'époque
donc il ya 4 5 ans c'était 35 ans le
raisonner ça me laissait une dizaine
d'années après ma thèse et sachant que
pour avoir un bon dossier il faut avoir
fait des postes à l'étranger donc
déménager tous les 2-3 ans mais des
déménagements vénère en mode changement
pays
ce dont je n'avais pas spécialement
envie et au delà de ça en plus moi je
voulais pas être juge chercheur je
voulais être maître de conf vraiment
parce que c'était important pour moi
d'avoir des moments où tu sors le nez du
guidon et est pas juste aux laboratoires
et l'enseignement ça me plaisait
vraiment beaucoup le côté transmission
de connaissances qu'on a dans la
vulgarisation on le retrouve aussi dans
l'enseignement est en fait les postes de
maîtres de conférences même une fois
qu'on a réussi à les avoir sont très
très compliqué parce que les maîtres de
conférences sont censés faire de
l'enseignement et de la recherche mais
ils sont aussi censés faire pleins
d'administratifs et en fait ils
travaillent à 150% et ils n'ont pas le
temps de faire toutes les missions qui
sont censés faire dans des conditions
souvent compliqué parce que bon c'est
bien que le budget c'est pas énorme
donc c'est pas énorme pour la recherche
n'est ce pas non plus énorme pour
l'enseignement moi j'ai déjà donné des
td pour quarante élèves
on est seul avec 30 chaise quoi et je ne
voyais pas faire ça toute ma vie donc je
me disais galéré pour peut-être avoir un
poste et si jamais j'ai un poste que les
conditions de travail en plus soit pas
folle je vais peut-être pas me lancer là
dedans je vais aller faire autre chose
c'est pour ça que j'ai arrêté mais le
quotidien de la recherche en soi et le
travail de chercheur c'était vraiment
quelque chose qui me plaisait beaucoup
du coup tu étais contente qu en dehors
fuentes vous avez tous regardent vers
vos tentes
alors ma thèse c'est pas franchement
très bien passé sur le plan humain
j'avais pas du tout la même vision du
monde et de la recherche que mon
directeur de thèse et du coup on a eu
beaucoup de mal à se comprendre sur
plein de trucs donc c'était un peu
moralement fatigant mais à aucun moment
je regrette d'avoir fait une thèse c'est
juste que je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut pas faire une thèse en se disant je
vais faire une thèse pour devenir
chercheur ouais ça j'étais bien placé
pour le savoir parce que tu as arrêté
après la tienne aussi mais la thèse
c'est une expérience intéressante on
apprend plein de trucs on apprend bien à
connaître ses propres limites aussi
c'est quelque chose d'hyper formateur
pour toute la suite
mais si on y va en se disant à la fin
j'aurais à un poste où on risque une
certaine déception
e s'il veut revenir par les atouts de
poids du passé qui est en veste or tu tu
lui diras ça quand même ouais je lui
dirai celle mais prépare ton plombé tout
de suite
attends pas la fin de ta thèse pour
préparer son plan b qu'est ce que tu
pense qu'il y assez de recherche en
biologie moléculaire ce qui est d'aider
plein d'opportunités
il faut à faire plus de recherche dans
le domaine
ça dépend comment on essaye de définir
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire comme
recherche il ya plein de questions
auxquelles ce serait important de
répondre rapidement et le problème c'est
que bas et comme il ya une grosse
variabilité pour répondre rapidement une
question poquet beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent dessus en fait quand on a
une chance de de trouver vite ou pour
développer parallèlement plein
d'hypothèses et trouver la bonne plus
vite qu'eux
on les fait séquentiellement dans
l'absolu oui ce serait bien qu'ils aient
plus de recherche
d'autant que moi j'étais en virologie
donc on a quand même un lien direct avec
des pathologies on sait que ça touche
des patients que ça peut avoir un vrai
impact rapide sur la vie des gens et
même au delà de ça à la recherche
fondamentale dont on ne voit pas les
implications peut à terme donner des
trucs énormes à christopher kas neuf
donc tout le monde parle maintenant qui
est un peu l'actu chaude de la biologie
moléculaire c'était de la recherche
fondamentale sans application à la base
donc c'est hyper important de continuer
à développer cette classe après chacun a
envie que tu peux expliquer un petit peu
crispé re s de fouet alors christopher
kas 9
à la base c'est quelque chose d'assez
cryptic qui en gros correspond à une
sorte de mémoire immunitaire génétique
chez les bactéries
c'est des séquences d adn a répété pour
trouver chez les bactéries et qui en
fait leur permettre de répondre à des
désinfections sauf que on s'est rendu
compte que ça pouvait aussi être utilisé
comme un outil pour faire des
modifications de l'adn
parce que la façon dont ça fonctionne
quand très très vulgariser c'est que il
ya une protéine qui va se fixer sur une
petite séquence d'acides nucléiques pour
aller reconnaître l'adn ou la rn d'un
virus et le coupé et ça c'est ce qui
fait que normalement ça empêche
l'infection sais que ça va se fixer sur
l'adn du virus est sale coupe et sa
garde en mémoire la séquence d'adn en
l'intégrant dans le génome qui fait que
si le virus revient ans alors recoupent
etc etc
sauf que en pratique pour un chercheur
ça c'est un outil pour aller modifier
l'adn à l'endroit qu'on veut de la façon
qu'on veut c'est hyper puissant parce
que jusqu'à maintenant les modifications
de l'adn où elle était faite au hasard
où elle était faite de façon ciblée mais
avec énormément de travail pour aller
cibler la séquence vérifier que ces
modifié comme il faut et c'est par moi
j'ai fait des clonages comme ça pour
produire des mutants pour modifier un
endroit précis de la séquence parce
qu'on sait que ça va avoir telle
conséquence sur la protéine et qu'on
voudrait voir si ça change ce qui se
passe et pour faire ça ça prenait
allez on va être gentille de trois
semaines facile avec chris burba s'est
fait en deux trois jours pour beaucoup
moins cher
donc on part vraiment de recherche très
fondamentale de comment les bactéries se
défendre contre les infections virales
et on arrive un outil de biologie
moléculaire hyper puissant rapide et peu
coûteux et donc qu'elle sera appelée les
applications pardon de christopher
cazenove qu'est ce que je pourrais faire
alors il ya les applications où on
utilise directement l'outil en recherche
fondamentale
j'ai besoin de savoir si tel endroit de
la protéine est important pour sa
fonction je peux aller le modifier très
facilement et voir si ça change quelque
chose ça je pense et la re re la ruche
qu'un cheveu ouais et ça je pense que en
pratique aujourd'hui c'est l'utilisation
principale de chris marquès neuf parce
que c'est quelque chose qui se fait de
façon très récurrente dans les labos de
recherche qui du coup maintenant est
hyper simplifié au delà de ça ça permet
de concevoir des projets de recherche
qu'on n'aurait pas pu envisager avant il
n'y a pas longtemps je suis tombé sur un
article hyper intéressant sur des gens
qui ont trouvé un remède alors un venin
une toxine je sais pas exactement mais
un poison sécrétée par pierre gorges
peintres comme ça un poison sécrétée par
un animal contre lequel une méduse ans
qu'on savait on n'avait pas de solution
et qui peut être mortelle très très
rapidement et en fait ils ont trouvé
d'où comment agissez le poison et
comment le bloquer en utilisant crise
peur pour produire plein de mutation sur
plein d'endroits différents du génome et
voir quelles mutations empêcher le venin
d'agir rigueur et produire une quantité
énorme de mutation dans tout le génome
comme ça sans crise peur c'est un
travail qui prend des années voiture de
vraiment avoir touché tous les endroits
et c'est avec respect il ya du travail
d'informatique pour automatiser un peu
le truc mais ça peut être fait en
quelques mois et du coup ça devient
envisageable de mettre en place des
projets de recherche comme ça 2 ça
change un peu ce qui peut être fait en
fait autant de bruit
à mon avis c'est un peu la même
différence que quand le séquençage est
devenu rapide et accessible
financièrement
à une époque on n'avait pas du tout les
séquences génétiques des outils avec
lesquels on travaille et parce que ma
pour faire un séquençage surprenait des
semaines ça coûtait une fortune et
maintenant n'importe qui peut faire
c'est quand c'est un truc en une semaine
pour quelques dizaines ou centaines
d'euros selon la longueur de la séquence
de ces rapports révolutionner la façon
dont on travaillait bacri spurs à un peu
la même chose et puis ça peut parfois
aussi de risques que ça pourrait poser
alors ça à titre personnel c'est ce que
je trouve le plus intéressant avec chris
peur c'est qu'on est vraiment sur une
technique qui s'est développée plus vite
que la réflexion éthique qui va avec
je pense que la plupart des gens quand
ils pensent à chrysler il pense aux
bébés qui a été génétiquement modifiés
par sa technique là parce que ma le fait
de pouvoir faire des modifications très
précises sans toxicité pour les cellules
en gros ça permet aussi de commencer à
réfléchir à de la génétique humaine à
les modifier une cellule f avant de
l'implanter avant le développement de
l'embryon et toutes les questions
éthiques qui sont liées à sa se sont
vraiment matérialisé sont devenues
importantes dans la tête des chercheurs
et la communauté en général parce que
l'outil est arrivé et c'est un peu les
même réflexion que toi tu peux avoir par
rapport aux ja je pense la situation
elle est là maintenant il faut qu'on y
réfléchisse très très vite parce qu'elle
va pas nous attendre pour continuer à se
développer c'est à la voix très
inquiétant est très intéressant il vous
serez coller aux risques pour chrysler
plus gros risques je peux pas donner des
idées aux gens moi les gens sont
bienveillants et ce qu'ils écoutent
j'espère non mais c'est alors ça a été
fait vraiment n'importe comment cette
histoire de modification génétique des
embryons mais en soit l'application de
pouvoir empêcher l'existence d'une
maladie génétique en corrigeant les
erreurs pour les familles concernées par
des maladies génétiques et qui peuvent
pas avoir d'enfant ou qui n'osent pas
d'enfants à cause de ça c'est
complètement révolutionnaire de même
pour les applications en thérapie
génique ou ce genre de choses il ya des
pistes hyper prometteuse mais ça veut
dire qu'on rentre dans tout ce qui est
modification du génome humain et là il
ya des questions qui se posent parce que
le fait que ce soit financièrement
accessible fait que c'est aussi
accessible en dehors des laboratoires
c'est à dire que moi demain si je veux
je peux commander des séquences d'adé
haine et me faire une injection de crise
peur ou de je ne sais quoi dans le bras
et pertinents mais je peux le faire
alors ça c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
spécifiques juste à crespin c'est
globalement la biologie moléculaire la
génétique moléculaire sont de plus en
plus accessible et du coup peuvent être
mises en place en dehors des
laboratoires
il ya un roman merveilleux qui s'appelle
je suis pilgrim qui est terriblement
angoissant parce qu'en gros c'est
l'histoire d'un terroriste qui décident
de recréer une souche de virus de la
variole et quand on lit ça en étant
virologues moléculaire on se rend compte
que c'est extrêmement crédible du coup
je pense qu'il ya des risques de attaque
biologique terroristes potentiels via ce
genre de technique mais il ya toujours
des risques d' attaque biologique
potentiel rien des années on parlait des
attaques à l'anthrax dans le métro et ce
genre de truc c'était déjà des attaques
biologiques hyper grave et hyper
dangereuse donc c'est pas c'est pas un
risque nouveau c'est juste que les
techniques de nuisance évolue donc les
outils de surveillance et les outils de
réponses doivent évoluer aussi je suis à
peu près sûr qu'ils ont évolué en même
temps et juste en tant que citoyen on
n'est pas au courant quoi ouais ça fait
plus de choses à survie c'est une
situation je sais que je connais pas la
source à jarry j'aurais peut être mais
jamais qui chacun qui aurait dit du coup
un truc du genre
au fur et à mesure que les technologies
avancent en fait le coup de poser une
catastrophe majeure diminuent également
c'est ça c'est exactement ça le coût et
les besoins techniques se sont
complètement effondrées et du coup les
change pas d'idée des scénarios de
pandémie c'est les choses qui sont
envisagées ça va les plans des lignes
comment dire les pandémies on est en
plein dedans au quotidien
il n'y a pas besoin de terroristes pour
ça qu évolué avec des agents pathogènes
depuis qu'on existe
lors des pandémies en cours la dernière
dont on a beaucoup entendu parler
cedicam et la pandémie de vih est
toujours pas terminée loin de là que
c'est mounir alors ça c'est ça va être
très provocateur mais je suis bien au
log
j'aime bien faire ça les virus et les
pathogènes ont autant le droit d'exister
que nous sur cette planète et il se
trouve que pour certains il existe en
use infectant avec des conséquences pas
terrible donc on n'arrivera jamais à les
éliminer
parce que les micro-organismes évolue
beaucoup plus vite que nous et que le
temps qu'on en élimine un il y en aura
dix autres qui vont potentiellement
apparaître mais oui on va en 10 avec des
pandémies faut pas que ce soit
angoissant parce qu'en fait c'est pas
nouveau depuis que l'humanité existe on
vit avec des pandémies est ce qu'elle
est chose à faire pour réduire les
risques soient des risques de pandémie
librement majeur est grave former des
autorités sanitaires compétentes et les
écouter quand elles nous disent de ne
pas faire ou de faire certaines choses
je pense est essentiellement ça parce
que le lait première étape pour lutter
contre les pandémies c'est d'avoir un
bon réseau de surveillance pour détecter
les soucis quand il arrive et ça
aujourd'hui on est plutôt bon même dans
des pays où le développement de suivi
médical est pas terrible pour des
raisons de moyens la surveillance se
fait quand même pas si mal veut donc là
dessus ça va après c'est vrai que mon la
cd très franco français mais on est un
peu réfractaire à l'autorité quand même
on va pas se mentir fut
c'est un mes profs de virologie qui nous
dans un cours sur le stress qui était un
virus respiratoires horrible hyper
contagieux qui se transmet par contact
indirect etc ou qui a contaminé tous les
passagers d'un avion où tous les
habitants d'un immeuble en passant par
les systèmes d'aération de ce genre de
truc qui nous disaient toujours on a eu
énormément de chance que ce virus là
apparaissent en chine parce qu'en chine
quand le gouvernement a dit 'vous
sortait plus de chez vous sans porter de
masque sans mettre de gants si vous avez
des risques d'infection et vont rester
enfermés pendant plusieurs semaines si
jamais vous êtes peut-être contagieux
tout le monde a écouté de alors que six
étaient apparus en france
ça aurait sans doute été beaucoup plus
compliqué de faire accepter des mesures
drastiques comme ça la population ouais
parce que du coup s'il faut un
comportement global il faut coordonner
pas mal de gens ça ce que ce soit du
coup les problèmes de faim ça ça fait
penser un peu aussi aux vaccins quoi
fait qu' il faut que tout le monde soit
par exemple moi et que s'il ya pas 95 %
de gens qui sont vaccinées baïla eddie
peut quand même 95 pour en gros le seuil
de personnes vaccinées pour qu'il y ait
une protection globale de la population
dépend du l'efficacité de contamination
et 95% de mémoire c'est le seuil minimal
pour protéger une population de la
rougeole qui est un virus
particulièrement contagieux et en france
on n'y est pas du tout et c'est pas pour
rien qu'il ya des poches épidémique de
rougeole qui ressorte un peu partout ces
dernières années donc oui bah oui en
france si tu veux je sais pas du tout et
je pense que ça doit évoluer assez
rapidement depuis qu'il ya eu
l'obligation vaccinale qui a été
introduite qui du coup a fait augmenter
réseau vaccination d'un côté mais
diminuer les vaccinations de l'autre
lorsqu'il ya des gens qui sont assez
réfractaire à ça et qu'ils n'ont pas
envie de se sentir obligé à le faire
qu'en soit je peux complètement
comprendre et c'est un pas si évident
que ça à suivre parce que comme c'est
censé être obligatoire les gens qui le
font pas sont obligées de cacher le fait
qu'ils le font pas
donc pour avoir une estimation réelle de
la couverture vaccinale c'est pas si
évident de l'otan qui a un effet locale
il ya un effet locale très fort c'est à
dire que s'il ya 100 % des gens qui sont
matinée un endroit mais 90 qui sont
vaccinées à côté bas à côté à landreau
il ya 90 % il y aura une épidémie voici
la rougeole arrive alors qu'en moyenne
ça peut arriver à 95 % de couverture
ouais mais du coup tu entends du coup je
pense que l'un des risques majeurs en
fait c'est la remise en cause des
autorités si le fait que des directives
qu'ils soient donnés par part par des
médecins ou des virologues ne soit pas
ça va ça si alors y'a pas des biens
russes ou des pathogènes hyperdangereux
hyper contagieux qui apparaissent tous
les deux jours non plus hein ça reste
quand même accès exceptionnel et en
général ça apparaît à un endroit et si
on arrive à le bloquer à cet endroit là
on est globalement tranquille mais c'est
sûr que si à l'endroit où ça apparaît
bain ou bien les gens n'écoutent pas les
autorités ou bien les autoritaires
raconte n'importe quoi
ou bien le réseau de surveillance et pas
assez qui casse par rapport à la vitesse
de contamination il va y avoir un
problème
après il ya des cas très différents par
exemple zika c'est devenu pandémique
parce que à la base ça faisait pas de
symptômes graves et du coup on s'en
méfier pas les symptômes graves sont
arrivés plus tard donc on n'est jamais à
l'abri après je pense que je commande
bien oui on peut beaucoup s'inquiéter de
ce genre de de risque biologique
je pense que si on comparait le nombre
de personnes qui ont eu des
complications médicales du asie cas et
le nombre de personnes pour lui des
complications médicales dus au tabac on
se rendrait compte qu'on est très très
bon pour se faire du mal tout seul et
qu'on n'a pas besoin des agents
pathogènes en effet
du coup je passe il a d'autres choses à
rajouter par rapport à ça je passais la
vulgarisation
ouais il ya un truc par rapport à
l'actualité de la recherche dans mon
ancien domaine que je trouve merveilleux
et que je suis à distance
c'est le retour de l'utilisation déviée
russe pour lutter contre les bactéries
on a un gros problème avec les bactéries
deviennent résistantes aux antibiotiques
et du bout des maladies contre été très
bien redevienne mortels et ça c'est un
problème généralisé à l'échelle de la
planète et il se trouve que il y à des
virus capable d'infecter de tuer tout et
n'importe quoi y compris les bactéries
et donc on peut utiliser des virus qu'on
appelle des bactériophages qui cible les
bactéries pour aller détruire des
bactéries pathogènes et c'est un truc
qui a été découvert il ya longtemps au
début du 20e siècle et qui est un peu
restée dans les oubliettes
loria un aspect très intéressant sur le
plan historique avec la guerre froide où
ça a été plus développé dans le bloc
soviétique parce qu'il n'avait pas trop
d'antibiotiques et du coup il essayait
de trouver une autre solution mais
globalement ça pas été très utilisé
parce que ben on manipule des virus donc
on manipule du vivant c'est moins
évident que de juste donner des
antibiotiques et ça fait peur au gens de
dire bon on va vous soigner avec des
virus clairement pas optimale sur le
plan pédagogique et est en fait
maintenant qu'on a plus vraiment de
nouveaux antibiotiques et qu'on a des
bactéries qui résistent à tous ceux
qu'on utilise en traitement il ya un
retour de l'utilisation des virus comme
potentiel loi de lutte contre les
bactéries
puis je m'étais technologies comme
christophe casanave peuvent permettre de
accéléré en tout cas là la conception de
sous leurs devis risque c'est ça parce
qu'on peut partir des bactériophages qui
existent se rendent compte qu en a aucun
qui ciblent exactement la bactérie comme
on voudrez mais comment ça allait
modifier un peu pour essayer d'être plus
efficace et ça c'est vraiment une
recherche qui est en train de se
développer là maintenant et qui à mon
avis va être hyper intéressante à suivre
dans les années qui arrivent plein de
choses à faire encore haye a du
potentiel et ils voulaient le six mètres
du coup on peut passer un petit peu apte
à de transition va faire la transition à
l'écran mais de transition tu as
commencé à t'intéresser à la médiation
scientifique pendant ta thèse où je suis
tombé dedans complètement par hasard en
allant faire du bénévolat pour filer un
coup de main sur la fête de la science
quand on est en tête souvent reçoit des
mails en disant oui on cherche les
intervenants pour faire tel atelier et c
est en fait il ya un bâtiment dédié à la
médiation scientifique qui a été créée
juste à côté de mon institut de
recherche pendant que j'étais en tête et
il fut comme ça venait de se créer il
abat envie de lancer plein de projets
mais ils manquaient de gens donc il ya
eu beaucoup d'appels à participation et
pour nous c'était facile
il y avait un couloir à traverser pour y
aller lille à un coup de main même avec
un emploi du temps bien chargé de
thésards c'était assez facile d'y aller
et un jour je me suis retrouvé à
écrabouiller des bananes avec des élèves
de ce2 entre comme ça et ça a vraiment
changé ma vie mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
tu voulais changer leur vie ouais c'est
ça en fait bon les cras brouillage de
banane c'est pour extraire de l'adn de
bananes donc c'est vraiment en lien avec
mon domaine à la base et je faisais déjà
de l'enseignement à la fac donc j'avais
déjà ce côté transmission du savoir mais
c'est très différent d'être sur un
public qui est pas là parce qu'il a un
partiel à la fin et ça a vraiment changé
quelque chose dans ma tête quoi de me
dire il ya un truc énorme à faire pour
aller intéresser les gens qui sont pas
forcément déjà intéressé et pourrait
donner des clés de compréhension à tout
le monde
et du coup j'ai continué à faire pas mal
de trucs de vulgarisation pendant ma
thèse notamment j'ai monté une pièce de
théâtre avec des chercheurs pour parler
du fonctionnement de la recherche car
réfléchir les gens ça a été mon gros
projets quand j'étais en tête qui
combine durée ouais c'était écrit low
cost
j'ai retravaillé une pièce de brecht
il s'appelle
la vie de galilée qui normalement dure
quatre heures avec 50 personnages pour
en faire un truc d'un peu moins de deux
heures avec une quinzaine de comédiens
doc est là et c'est quand même un projet
qui m'a occupé bien pendant ma dernière
année de thèse bref le moment le plus
tranquille fort oui mais comme j'avais
déjà décidé d'arrêter la recherche et
que mon mât publication était déjà sorti
je continue à travailler sur un projet
mais je savais que de toute façon je le
finirais pas avant de partir donc
j'avais pas la même pression qu'on peut
avoir en fin de thèse quand vraiment il
faut boucler les trucs
sinon ça va mal se passer j'ai eu un
début de thèse compliqué mais une femme
thèse plutôt confortable voilà donc j'ai
pu monter ce truc là assez
tranquillement et à mon directeur de
thèse savait que de toute façon
j'arrêterai la recherche pour aller
faire de la vulgarisation après et que
en fait en montant ce projet là j'étais
en train de préparer la suite
c'était assez cohérent de et tous mes
comédiens étaient des gens qui
travaillaient dans l'enseignement
supérieur ou la recherche ou des gens en
lien avec ce bidule up donc ça restait
quand même assez cohérent avec le
travail de laboratoire
et puis dans les comédiens il y avait le
fils de mon directeur de thèse donc de
tout
moralement engagé voilà mes donc j'ai
monté ce projet là et ça m'a vraiment
conforté quoi ça m'a permis de tester
c'est quoi la réalité d'un projet de
vulgarisation scientifique quand on gère
tout de a à z
est-ce que ça me plaît vraiment ou pas
élément ça m'a plu donc j'ai continué à
travailler dans ce domaine là ok voilà
ce que vous avez fait plusieurs
représentations du coup on a joué une
dizaine de fois quand même moins on
était on était sur montpellier on est
quand même monté la jouer jusqu'à nancy
cette pièce mais c'était pas mal ça
avait honnêtement ça a plutôt bien
marché et surtout moi ce que je trouve
le plus beau c'est que moi je suis parti
de montpellier après ma thèse
mais la troupe de théâtre existe encore
que
la pièce s'appelait galilée 2.0 à
l'époque et la troupe s'appelle
maintenant galilée 3.0 ils sont en train
de préparer leur troisième spectacle
alors donc même sur le plan humain c'est
une aventure qui continue à bien marcher
c'est super du coup je mets une tétée
aussi rencontré des gens pendant ce que
tu étais technique parce que du coup
c'était été endossé par le sénat
l'institut de recherche ou non cet or
dossiers par mois
il ya un peu un fil rouge dans ma vie
qui est que quand j'ai envie de faire un
truc
bah si c'est trop compliqué de le faire
porter par quelqu'un d'autre est de
trouver une structure administrative etc
c'est pas grave je le fais tout seul
après ça a été beaucoup soutenu parce
que il ya quand même un certain budget
quoi pour monter une pièce avec quinze
personnes des décors et en plus c'était
une pièce qui était pas libre de droit
donc il y avait des frais à payer à
chaque représentation aux ayants droit
et du coup c'est est financé par la
mairie c'était financées par le conseil
départemental par les universités etc a
eu quand même beaucoup de soutien c'est
moi qui portait le projet mais tous les
gens à qui j'ai demandé du soutien m'ont
soutenu ça c'était assez agréable et
donc du coup dur après tout tu évites à
thèze et du coup tu t'es lancé dans le
chômage
très exactement une des raisons pour
lesquelles ça a été compliqué c'est que
j'ai déménagé à l'autre bout de la
france dans les quelques mois qui ont
suivi ma femme thèse poursuivre mon
conjoint qui avait été muté et qui lui
avait un cdi donc clairement sa
situation professionnelle était beaucoup
plus stable que la mienne à l'époque et
il n'y avait même pas réfléchir trois
secondes s'il bouge et il fallait que je
suis quoi eux et du coup j'ai perdu tout
mon réseau parce que parce que va quand
on est en tête et qu'on fait des trucs à
côté de sa thèse c'est pas évident de
développer un réseau qui soit autre
chose que local donc je connaissais très
bien tous les gens autour de chez moi et
puis j'étais à montpellier je me suis
retrouvé en normandie réinitialisation
totale du site
à mon avis c'était le premier gros
handicap et le deuxième handicap c'est
qu'en général quand on commence dans la
médiation qu'on commence sur des postes
de médiateurs terre de gens qui animent
des ateliers et à l'époque ces postes
étaient souvent en contrats aidés et
quand on sort de tête on n'a pas droit à
un contrat aidé
ce qui est assez logique en soi parce
que c'est un dispositif qui devait
permettre aux gens peu diplômés vont
retourner dans l'emploi ou clairement un
docteur c'était pas le bon profil et
j'ai vu passer énormément d'offres de
postes auxquelles je pouvais même pas
candidaté en fait ça d'ailleurs mon
premier poste que j'ai fini par avoir au
bout de quatorze mois c'était en contrat
aidé c'est juste que comme j'étais
chômeur longue durée pour basculer dans
la catégorie des gens qui avaient droit
à cette rue classe c'était un peu le
double handicap
et puis au delà de ça quand on arrive
avec un cv de docteur ben c'est pas
forcément ce que les gens cherchent quoi
deux il ya des structures où ça a plu
alors j'avais candidater à l'inserm et
j'avais été très bien classé sur un
poste parce que eux ça les intéressait
d'avoir quelqu'un qui connaissait le
milieu de la recherche
mais c'est sûr que pour un employeur
quelqu'un qui sort d'un master de
communication scientifique d'être plus
intéressant que quelqu'un qui sort d'un
doctorat en n'ayant que de l'expérience
extra-professionnelles 2 le plus dur ça
a été de trouver le premier poste depuis
que j'ai eu le premier poste tous les
autres se sont enchaînées sans aucun
aucun souci mais au début ça a vraiment
été compliqué du coup tout le pré et
post cette école alors c'était
médiatrice scientifique à l'espace des
sciences pierre gilles de gennes qui est
un musée de sciences liées le spcj à
paris l'école supérieure de physique et
de chimie industrielles qui est juste à
côté de levens est ce parce que du coup
j'avais fait normale sup donc en fait
j'ai mis dix ans pour revenir au pâté de
maison d'à côté est du coup mais c'était
vraiment pour un premier poste c'était
top
hier que c'était très très formateur il
y avait des ateliers qui fonctionnait
très bien qu'ils étaient des ateliers
grand public
il y avait des projets avec des
scolaires il y avait un peu de tout du
coup j'ai travaillé avec tous les types
de publics différents
de la maternelle au lycée aux familles
et c'est ça c'était maintenant je sais
quel public je préfère je peux vraiment
dire que je sais parce que j'ai tout
tester eux
du coup ce que le public que tu cru en
moi je préfère les familles mais j'aime
c'est pas le public le plus facile pour
les animations parce que c'est un public
hétérogène mais c'est le public le plus
intéressant parce que c'est celui qui a
le plus à apporter
alors que quand on fait une activité
devant une classe à peu près tous les
élèves ont le même profil ou lui-même
connaissance et du tout si on essaye de
les impliquer dans la création de
l'atelier parce que c'est ce que je
trouve intéressant moi la différence
entre une vidéo sur youtube où on va
donner un public mais sans retour direct
et un atelier où vraiment tout le monde
est dans la même pièce
moi j'essaye toujours de penser ça comme
un moment des changes et que ça
fonctionne dans les deux sens et du coup
si on a un public hétérogène où chacun a
vraiment une expérience différente et
des connaissances différentes
l'échangé beaucoup plus riche de et
puisque tu goûtes à pita pas le problème
que ce que j'entends souvent savez que
lorsque c'est une famille rom bat l'ebbe
parents ils se mettent un peu derrière
ils me laissent un faux châssis mais ça
c'est le travail du médiateur de se
débrouiller pour rien impliqué les
parents doit aller les chercher les gens
et du coup de fil comment moi je
commence toujours mes ateliers par me
présenter dire qui je suis et c'est et
si c'est un atelier avec un public
famille je dis clairement cet atelier
n'est pas que pour les enfants décédés
participer en premier pour répondre aux
questions mais n'hésitez pas à poser les
vôtres et à proposer les réponses et je
suis aussi là pour vous et les gens se
prennent au jeu très très vite 2 quand
on pose une question et qu'aucun des
enfants à la réponse de ces moments où
il faut se retourner vers les parents et
dia alors et vous vous en pensez quoi
et puis une fois qu'ils ont commencé à
rentrer dans le jeu ça se fait tout seul
vague et que c'est parce que là du coup
tu avais déjà commencé ta chaîne youtube
com cette émission j'ai soutenu ma thèse
en juillet 2015 et j'ai lancé la chaîne
youtube manches et plus en septembre ou
en octobre
et cette année je pense avoir une chaîne
youtube pour ce que j'en sais rien sur
ce poste là je ne suis pas sûr je sais
que ça
m'a aidé de façon générale pour
développer un réseau clairement parce
que j'ai passé aucun poste où les gens
n'avaient pas regarder mes vidéos alors
que clairement sur mon cv c'était un
élément qui attirait l'attention après
vu le nombre de candidatures qui n'ont
pas marché je pense que ce n'était pas
un élément déterminant dans l'armée mais
les gens à les regarder en tout cas donc
ça il y avait il y avait un intérêt pour
ça et ça m'a permis en fait youtube a
ouvert plein de portes
ce qui est intéressant c'est pas tant la
chaîne en soi que le fait que avoir
cette chaîne m'a permis d'écrire un
chapitre dans un bouquin est d'être
invités à des trucs par rapport au livre
que j'ai participé à des tables rondes
avec d'autres vulgarisateur etc etc
et du coup quand on connaît les gens
c'est beaucoup plus simple de travailler
ensemble ensuite je pense que ça a
vraiment été une clé pour le réseau et
parce que de toute façon pour que la
chaîne soit visible ça implique de
communiquer autour de la chaîne et c'est
aussi comme ça que je m'étais mise à
l'époque sur twitter à la fois pour
chercher du travail et pour rendre la
chaîne le plus visible possible
du coup massacrer des échanges assez
efficacement ya déjà à l'époque avait
cet effet de mode au tour de youtube où
tout de suite ça intéressait les gens s
à lancer des discussions
je pense qu'on est plusieurs je sais
comme moi j'ai d'abord lancé ma chaîne
youtube et puis après si beau que je
communique du coup je me suis mis un peu
sur twitter et puis j'ai maintenant je
suis addict à twitter mais clairement ce
que du coup y'a pas il ya tout un réseau
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
vulgarisateur que par la caisse compte
twitter doivent être plus ou moins sûr
sur twitter et du coup ça permet des
champions je pense que twitter c'est
vraiment le réseau social des
professionnels de la culture
scientifique en général berk on y trouve
assez naturellement les gens qui ont des
chaînes youtube et qui du coup sont un
peu sur les réseaux sociaux
mais même au delà de ça les centres de
sciences et que c'est de plus en plus
souvent des comptes twitter de douai
après ton post donc après ce premier
post du coup à braaten tafer coque alors
je suis parti de travailler dans la
branche science et société d'une
fondation qui finançait pas qu'ils
financent tout journée c'est la
fondation tout comme hergé pour
l'enseignement et la recherche
qui finance des chercheurs en biologie
santé donc ça rejoignait un petit peu
mon domaine à la base mais nous ce qu'on
vous ait été monté concevoir des actions
de vulgarisation scientifique en
impliquant des chercheurs en gros que et
là dedans j'ai travaillé surtout ma sur
la bio aux labos qui est un conte
collaboratif sur twitter facebook et
instagram qui animait chaque semaine par
un personnel de recherche différents en
biologie donc ça s'est impliqué d'aller
motiver les gens parce que ben tout le
monde et pas sur les réseaux sociaux
donc c'est pas évident de les
accompagner et de faire des résumés pour
que ça serve alors que c'est bien que
les gens à nîmes le 11 mai c'est mieux
si un site qui centralise toutes les
biographies ou les gens qui se posent
des questions sur les métiers de la
recherche peuvent aller regarder à quoi
correspondent les différents profils
quels sont les différents domaines de
recherche en biologie etc etc donc
essayer de rendre la ressource vraiment
exploitable et l'autre gros projet à cet
endroit là c'était le déclic qui
consiste à faire venir des personnels de
recherche dans les lycées pour discuter
directement avec les lycéens moi j'avais
organisé la session 2010 est du coup si
je ne trompe pas et on avait quand même
fait venir plus de 700 personnels de
recherche dans une cinquantaine de
lycées en france
du coup là c'est intéressant parce que
c'était très différent de mon premier
post mon premier poste j'étais vraiment
exécutante sur le terrain on va dire
alors que là je faisais tout sauf
l'exécution sur le terrain en en termes
de formation et puis pour voir ce qui
m'intéressait de plus je pense que
c'était les deux meilleurs premiers
postes possibles pour avoir tout tester
elle se faire un avis et du coup ma vie
je j'aime beaucoup coordonner des
projets et d'ailleurs je continue à le
faire c'est pas pour rien mais je trouve
que c'est très frustrant d'être vraiment
coupé du terrain on se le ski m'a lancé
dans la médiation scientifique à la base
c'était un atelier avec des scolaires et
je pense que c'est pas pour rien j'ai
vraiment besoin et envie d'aller voir
des gens le compteur les changes
et donc ensuite la suite on part de
ouais bah alors tout ça c'était une
période un peu compliquée parce que
j'habitais en normandie et je
travaillais à paris donc des gens vers
le retour
ouais je faisais des allers retours et
au delà de ça moi je suis du sud
clairement je suis né à marseille j'ai
grandi à côté de toulouse j'ai fait ma
thèse à montpellier donc la vie en
normandie c'était pas l'oreille absolue
donc mon objectif de 2018 s'était
retourné dans le sud
voilà du lieu et du coup bas twitter
j'ai fait un tweet en disant que je
cherchais un temps partiel idéalement à
toulouse ou bordeaux
et c'est là que les responsables de
leurs et café se sont manifestés
confirma écoute on a un projet de
vulgarisation à toulouse
ce serait peut-être bien qu'on est
quelqu'un qui a un peu de bouteille dans
le métier pour nous aider à monter les
ateliers etc et on s'est vu quelques
fois on a discuté et puis j'ai commencé
à bosser alors et café deux semaines
après l'ouverture
donc ça s'est fait très très loin que
fut tu peux présenter un peu le riz café
ouais donc l'horeca fait c'est le
premier café scientifique de france qui
a ouvert à toulouse en avril 2018
un petit fonctionne sur le modèle de
l'antique a fait c'est à dire que les
gens payent pas à la consommation ils
payent au temps passé sur place et tout
est en libre service
le mot d'ordre du lieu s'est faites
comme chez vous voilà c'est un café où
il ya une partie café avec des tables et
des chaises mais il ya aussi une partie
avec des canapés des tables basses pour
se poser tranquillement et c'est
vraiment pensé la façon de le dire c'est
que c'est un café des curiosités
au delà de l'étiquette science qui
justement peut faire un peu peur aux
gens le but c'est que ce soit un lieu
neutre avec plein de petits points
d'accrochage partout pour les curieux il
ya des passes milian fourmilière il ya
une bibliothèque il ya plein d'objets
liés aux sciences mais qui sont là pour
lancer des discussions et pour attirer
le regard
et en parallèle de sa en soirée il ya
toute une programmation à vocation
pédagogique ou peut il ya des
conférences faites par des chercheurs
il ya des tables rondes il ya des
soirées théâtre d'impro et vulgarisation
il ya plein plein de formats différents
et voilà donc c'est assez un lieu un peu
de
l'idée c'était de sortir les sciences
des endroits étiquetés comme
scientifique repose forcément une partie
du public et d'être avant tout un lieu
convivial dans lequel il se trouve qu'il
ya du contenu scientifique qui du coup
peuvent être accessibles à des gens un
peu différent c'est vrai parce que
disait michael quand j'ai intégré qu'ils
aient raté accès aux journaux les
enfants faire des maths pas fait des
maths dans votre coin nouveau mois
uniquement jeter un oeil aux airs mais
qu'est ce que tu fais mais c'est un peu
ça et puis surtout leur dites pas que
c'est des maths
voilà sur leur faire du rubik's cube ou
des trucs comme ça il est en fait ils
vont aimer les maths sans se rendre
compte que c'est des maths et ça vaut
pour tous du coup tu travaillais encore
alors et café ou non alors du coup mon
contrat s'est terminé au début du mois
là où quelque 15 jours parce que c'est
un endroit qui se lance donc qui est pas
encore complètement rentable sur le plan
économique
en gros c'est normal un pour un commerce
faut compter à peu près trois ans pour
fidéliser une clientèle et du coup moi
mon rôle ça a été de lancer nos propres
ateliers
donc il ya des ateliers qui sont conçus
et c est là il ya plus besoin de moi
pour les faire tourner donc l'objectif
ce serait bien que les gestionnaires
arrive à se payer eux payé moi mais
voilà après c'est un lieu auquel je
reste très attaché parce que vraiment je
pense que l'idée merveilleuse et que la
réalisation est bien fait et qu' il
faudrait que j'en ai partout donc là j'y
suis plus parce que pour des raisons
économiques c'était compliqué d'y rester
mais j'y crois vraiment très très fort
et j'ai ce tueur sont contents de leur
projet bah je pense pour leur demander
où ils seront sur twitter aussi
non vraiment moi ce que ce que j'ai
trouvé assez merveilleux dans ce lieu
est quoi je m'attendais pas du tout
c'est l'engouement des chercheurs
vraiment parce que pour du coup sûr mon
poste d'avant je passais mon temps à
essayer de mobiliser des chercheurs pour
des actions de vulgarisation et on se
rend bien compte très vite que c'est
toujours les mêmes motivés qui sont
moteurs et la l'horeca fait très
régulièrement on a des chercheurs qu'on
ne connaît pas qui semaine
est pour dire moi j'aimerais bien faire
de la vulgarisation donner une référence
est ce que c'est possible de le faire
chez vous et ça vraiment c'est hyper
rassurant la communauté locale est très
très mobilisé le fait qu'il ya un lieu
qui arrive
bah ça suscite des vocations pour le
remplir en proposant des activités
savoura passé un truc que je trouve très
très rassurant et très très positif très
chouette du coup maintenant chanson quel
projet m a du coup là je travaille pour
une association qui s'appelle délires
d'encre qui est une association qui a
pour but de vulgariser la science par le
prisme des livres en gros le créneau de
vulgarisation c'est ça qui organise un
festival notamment qui s'appelle
scientilivre tous les ans avec des
auteurs l'année dernière il avait un
certain pierre karner vérité sur moi
parasites
on y était allé avec le cat et des
chances aussi pour parler du livre du
café des sciences
mais du coup il ya plein d'ouvragés
scientifiques à vocation pédagogique
comme ça qui sont utilisés avec les
auteurs qui s'impliquent dans le
festival
et il ya des stands de vulgarisation et
c est un deuxième festival qui s'appelle
terre d'ailleurs qui est plus axée
autour de l'exploration mais est il ya
tout un paul de médiation où il ya des
interventions qui sont faites dans des
écoles dans des centres de loisirs dans
des médiathèques et il ya un gros
travail qui est fait avec les
médiathèques ou pour développer plus les
activités scientifiques dans ce contexte
là qui souvent est considéré comme très
littéraire alors qu'en fait une
médiathèque ce avant tout un lieu
culturel dont les sciences ont
complètement leur place dans un lieu
culturel
voilà c'est un des gros axes de travail
et ya aussi on développe des escape game
pédagogique il ya déjà un escape game
qui a été fait l'année dernière pour la
fête de la science avec science
animation qui un escalier games qui est
en fait conçu pour être donnée clé en
main sur internet et n'importe qui peut
le monte et qui est pensé pour les
médiathèques donc qu'ils reposent sur le
fait d'avoir des étagères de livres en
gros mais voilà il ya un sbm itinérant
qui se passe dans la station spatiale
internationale
là y en a un nouveau conte en train de
finir il ya aussi l'idée de s'approprier
un peu ce format mais sur un mode
itinérant pour aller voir directement
les gens et leur proposer un outil de
médiation hyper ludiques jeux et moi là
dedans mon objectif ça va être de
coordonner le pôle médiation ce que du
coup comme ya plein de projets dans tous
les sens c'est important que ce soit
bien coordonnée pour rester efficace et
donc j'ai bientôt travailler sur un
nouveau projet sur lequel je peux pas
encore trop en dire mais que je trouve
absolument merveilleux et je suis super
excité on à la première réunion de
travail demain c'est vrai il ya des
trucs très très chouette qui se prépare
et du coup ils font actuellement lé
faire des animations
parce que comme je disais c'est un truc
qui vous tient à coeur et qui pour moi
est hyper important et ce poste là
permet ça d'avoir à la fois l'aspect
coordination et l'aspect rester sur le
terrain quand même et ça c'est 1 60%
ouais donc il faut occuper le 40 % de
temps restant et c'est un choix d'être
sur un 60 % parce qu'il ya pas mal
d'activités sur lesquels je travaille ma
notamment biosciences est la chaîne qui
a été monté par la main à la pâte sur
une idée de david louapre le fameux des
lois pour proposer des outils pour
permettre aux enseignants de primaire
notamment et de maternelle de développer
massivement des activités scientifiques
dans leur classe donc on est tout un
groupe
7-8 vidéaste à travailler avec eux pour
faire des vidéos il ya ça qui prend
quand même un peu de temps aussi qui est
très chouette
et puis les trucs pas encore concrétisée
mais on y travaille plus mal à l'idée
c'est moi je suis auto entrepreneur
depuis un moment
parce que toi tu as dû avoir le même
genre de constat que quand et vidéaste
et rapidement sollicité pour faire des
choses que faire des choses entièrement
bénévole mamba un moment c'est plus
possible parce que sept membres du
travail ont plus de ton travail et que
les vidéos sont déjà bénévole et que le
loyer n'est pas payée en visibilité ou
en fauteuil
ça ne marche pas donc je n'avais jamais
fait un statut auto entrepreneur pour
pouvoir de la junte en être rémunérés
pour mes interventions
et là j'ai envie de vraiment essayé de
lancer ça plus sérieusement pour faire
alors je déteste ce mot mais en pratique
c'est ça pour faire une structure de
conseil en culture scientifique parce
que ouais ça c'est un constat que tu as
sans doute fait aussi ce serait hyper
important que les chercheurs vulgarise
plus leurs travaux et qu'on est plus
conscience de ce qui se passe dans les
laboratoires de recherche ce qui se
passe plein de choses intéressantes
d'une part et parce que c'est souvent
financer avec de l'argent public
d'autre part donc c'est un peu la
moindre des choses rendent compte aux
citoyens de ce qu'on fait avec leur
argent public mais c'est pas un truc qui
est très ancrée dans la culture
académique c'est pas valorisées dans les
évaluations de carrière c'est pas
valorisées dans les critères de
recrutement alors que paradoxalement ça
fait officiellement partie des missions
des chercheurs dans le code de la
recherche c'est une des missions des
chercheurs la diffusion de la culture
scientifique
c'est dans la liste des missions des
chercheurs au cnrs etc mais en pratique
ça se fait peu ça se fait peu parce
qu'elle pas vu la proportion qui en a on
peut dire qu'il ya pas de poste de
médiateur dans les structures de
recherche
il ya des postes de chargés de com qui
font des communiqués de presse pour
valoriser les publications etc
il n'y a pas de poste de médiateur pour
faire connaître les thématiques
générales de recherche et c'est dommage
et là ça fait quelques mois que je
travaille avec un ancien camarade de
master qui lui a continué la recherche
qui en post doc pour vulgariser ces
travaux parce qu'en fait il a eu un
financement de recherche européen ou en
fait dans les financements de recherche
européen il ya une case
quand on décrit son projet qui s'appelle
outreach qu'on pourrait traduire par
vulgarisation diffusion et qui consiste
en gros à proposer un projet pour
vulgariser les recherches auprès d'un
public données du grand public des
scolaires peu important un chacun le
détermine et lui avait proposé un projet
autour de vidéos pédagogiques et il a eu
son financement
donc on travaille sur ce projet de
vidéos pédagogiques et et c'est hyper
intéressant à faire
et je pense vraiment que c'est utile de
faire sortir la recherche des labos et
que les gens se rendent compte qu'il se
passe des trucs et j'aimerais développer
ça serait accompagné un peu les
chercheurs qui voudraient faire de
vulgarisation ouais mais là ça va
beaucoup dépendre des besoins que les
gens me font remonter pour l'instant
l'idée générale c'est de proposer un
accompagnement à la conception ou à la
réalisation de projets de vulgarisation
le public premiers ce sera les
chercheurs parce que je pense que c'est
là qu'il ya le plus de besoin
aujourd'hui je suis quelqu'un qui est
pas du tout chercheur me contacter je
vais dd quand même c'est pas moi c'est
pas un prêteur éliminatoires mais je
pense que c'est l'homme il ya plus de
choses à faire et ça me permettrait
aussi d'utiliser pas tout ce réseau qui
s'est mis en place ces dernières années
ou en fait quand on regarde les
vulgarisateurs d'internet en général il
ya plein de gens qui ont des talents
absolument merveilleux qui travaillent
en indépendants un peu tout seuls dans
leur coin et qui sont clairement pas
assez sollicités pour ceux qui savent
faire c'est à dire que pas un second
mandat
il ya des gens qui lui qu'on sollicite
parce qu'ils font des vidéos et on les
fait parler de vidéo alors qu'on
pourrait les faire parler de
vulgarisation voir leur faire faire de
la vulgarisation c'est quand même plus
intéressant mais plus rares moi je sais
qu'en tant que guide est à 7 en général
on m'invite à des tables rondes pour
parler de la vidéo sur internet
mais on m'a dit pas à faire des
conférences de vulgarisation assez
rarement ya tout un une manne de
personnes compétentes la mobiliser sur
le sur des projets et je pense que j'ai
le réseau et les compétences qu'il faut
aujourd'hui pour faire ce lien là donc
on va essayer et on verra bien si ça
marche ou pas mais il ya un truc à faire
c'est un truc dont on parlait avec
stephen du fait que bon je pense qu'il
ya quand même
voyez comme des chercheurs qui
s'intéressent ou des instituts de
recherche qui s'intéressent de plus en
plus à faire de la vulgarisation
et du coup la question c'est un peu
est-ce que c'est aux chercheurs de
vulgariser ou à ce que vous pouvez avoir
un médiateur qui qui qui du triste bien
le domaine et qui vulgarise à la place
du chercheur
ça c'est un débat récurrent est ce qu'il
faut être chercheur pour parler de ses
recherches à s'il faut forcément un
médiateur dans un projet de médiation
moi je pense que ce qui compte surtout
c'est lent vie des gens parce que on
fera jamais rien de bien si on n'a pas
vraiment envie de le faire il ya des
chercheurs qui sont très motivés par la
vulgarisation et qui ont potentiellement
besoin d'un accompagnement au début
parce qu'il ya des conseils quand même
pratique quand on a fait de la médiation
on a testé sur le terrain si on peut
éviter à quelqu'un de refaire les mêmes
erreurs que nous tant mieux mais il ya
des chercheurs qui n'ont pas besoin de
plus que ses conseils là qui sont très
très bon qui passe bien à l'oral qui ont
du charisme qui sont drôles etc
aucun souci là-dessus d'une année à pau
c'est drôle c'est dire ouais
les chercheurs sont des êtres humains
révélations mais à côté ça il ya aussi
des chercheurs qui peuvent avoir une
énorme envie de partager mais pas de le
faire eux mêmes directement eux mais
c'est un gars comme intérêt pour les
chercheurs c'est un peu la mise en avant
de leur domaine de recherche est qui qui
qui est important que qui est valorisant
pour le chercheur principal chercheur
lui même qui le fait qu à oui et c'est
un peu ce qu'on disait quand j'étais à
la fondation sur mes regrets pour
l'éducation et la recherche
pour motiver les chercheurs à participer
on leur expliquait que ça concerne pas
juste eu en tant qu'individu mais que
valoriser leurs domaines de recherche
c'est une bonne chose en tant que nom
pour le regard de la société
mais ça peut aussi avoir un impact sur
les financements je veux dire un domaine
de recherche qui à la mode et qui
intéresse tout le monde sait aussi
beaucoup plus facile de faire financer
des projets de recherche
donc c'est intéressant pour les citoyens
mais c'est aussi intéressant pour les
chercheurs mais quand on discute avec
des gens comme pierre karner par exemple
il lui dit toujours que la vulgarisation
salle a énormément aidé dans son
activité d'enseignement par exemple
parce que tu vois les sujets d'une façon
différente du cross des choses que tu
aurais pas creuser parce que ben t'as
peur qu'on me pose une question dessus
alors du coup il faut être irréprochable
sur tout
et en faisant ça tu découvres des pistes
de réflexions nouvelles ou qu'elle
n'avait pas du tout pensé je pense c'est
que un avantage de faire ça et on pourra
jamais impliquer les gens de force
donc c'est aussi pour ça que c'est
important de travailler en équipe et que
si un chercheur envie de vulgariser son
domaine et qu'il n'a pas envie de
montrer sa tête par exemple qu'il n'a
pas envie de parler en public
bon on peut réfléchir à concevoir un
projet où il peut s'impliquer sans avoir
besoin de faire ça et puis ça peut être
aussi difficile de concilier faut que ce
soit pierre ou pierre karner où je
parlais à mehdi moussaïd aussi récemment
d'autres chercheurs comme ça qu'ils sont
vraiment chercheurs et qui sont aussi
très actifs en bulgare isation mais
l'activité de vulgarisation comptant
aussi s'ils écrivent un livre en plus
d'enfants ils ont une chaîne youtube ça
s'apprend prennent beaucoup beaucoup de
temps et peut-être qu'à des parties de
ce trail de ces travaux qui veulent
délégués ou ou juste collaborer avec peu
de personnes qui prennent une partie de
ce travail ça peut être intéressant
je pense qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose
à faire là dessus que c'est pas facile à
mettre en place pour des grosses
institutions parce que ben plus le la
chaîne de validation est compliqué plus
ça demande du temps plus il ya de
l'inertie et voilà six mois à titre
personnel je peux ne serait-ce qu aider
un ou deux projets de vulgarisation à
voir le jour ce sera déjà une grande
réussite
c'est vrai que ça c'est un point aussi
intéressant ce que le enfin j'ai lu tous
les projets de beaucoup de projets qui
ont très bien marché sur initiative de
certaines personnes notamment les
chaînes youtube
ça marche très bien aussi en partie
parce que les personnes sont très libre
et très dépendante pas parce qu'ils font
sur youtube on publie la vidéo avant de
peut-être la vie dans ou deux amis mais
mais ça va très vite et c'est très
important pour avoir rapidement du
feedback pour s'améliorer aussi pour un
processus d'itérations assez rapide et
puis aussi ça permet de tout projet de
voir le jour plus rapidement alors que
si on passe par des institutions ainsi
s'il ya cinq personnes qui doivent
donner leurs habitations
les emails parfois mettre du temps à
venir
et du coup c'est quand même important ça
c'est intéressant du coup de cibler
directement les chercheurs plutôt que
d'essayer de cibler les institutions à
ce niveau là que c'est en weppes lui
plus on a une chaîne de validation long
important de plus à prendre du temps
mais en plus plus ça va être difficile
de mettre tout le monde d'accord
et puis de motiver les gens parce que
enfin si ça prend plus de temps bateau
ne se démotive la version circuits
courts de la vulgarisation ici et donc
sinon tu as aussi usé c'est à intéresser
pas mal aux vidéastes la vulgarisation
et à maman l'aspect financier tout ça
quand tu as fait quelques sondages ce
que tu peux nous en parler un petit peu
ouais bah ça revient parce que je disais
tout à l'heure quand je me pose des
questions que j'ai envie de faire des
trucs
si ça existe pas déjà et que je peux le
faire tout seul en général je le fais
tout seul et quand je me suis lancée
dans la vidéo en discutant avec les gens
j'avais l'impression qu'on était hyper
nombreux à voir des situations très
précaires et que c'était notamment une
des raisons pour lesquelles c'était
problématique de faire des interventions
de bénévoles ce que ma pendant des
chômeurs ou étudiants prendre plein de
temps pour faire du bénévolat côté au
bout d'un moment ça atteint ses limites
et je me suis demandé à quel point
c'était une intuition ou si c'était
vraiment fondées et pourquoi j'ai fait
un questionnaire que j'ai diffusé aux
vidéastes alors scientifique donc c'est
beaucoup passé par le café des sciences
vidéo sur ans à l'époque et savait aussi
pas mal tourné sur twitter donc j'avais
eu des réponses de gens que je
connaissais pas du tout quoi c'est pas
juste rester dans mon cercle proche
avait un peu plus de 4
lundi répondant et ça en fait ça pas mal
contient et mes intuitions parce qu'il y
avait quand même 10 % de gens au chômage
beaucoup d'étudiants pas mal de
doctorants mais aucun doctorants non
financées à l'époque tous les doctorants
qui prenaient du temps pour faire des
activités à côté c'était des gens qui
avaient déjà le confort d'un contrat de
travail et ça confirme et aussi surtout
que une chaîne youtube n'est pas un
moyen pertinent de gagner sa vie parce
que la plupart des gens avaient un bilan
financier négatif même pas notre c'est
négatif m'a fait perdre de l'argent et
en plus à mon avis dans ce bilan la
personne compte que temps de travail
c'est vraiment juste matériellement en
fait ça coûte cher de faire des vidéos
po et caméra il faut un micro au point
un logiciel de montage éventuellement tu
vois un bon ordinateur aussi et puis ça
prend beaucoup de temps de faire la
vidéo je pense qu'on peut être un truc
sur lequel on peut assister les gens ne
se rend pas forcément compte du travail
que ça retient surtout quand on fait de
la vulgarisation parce que en ce qu on
est assez nombreux a passé énormément de
temps à travailler avant même d'appuyer
sur le bouton de la caméra en termes de
biblio et de re lecture et d'écriture du
script un mois c'est la partie la plus
longue du travail mais de très très loin
mais j'ai tellement peur de dire un truc
faux ou d'oublier un axe important du
sujet que je veux traiter que j'ai puisé
difficile de quantifier parce que ça
enfin moi je fais des vidéos sur des
trucs de l'état vie mais du coup ça fait
des années que je baigne dedans que
commence qui quantifie ça mais voilà et
du coup mon j'avais fait une première
enquête et j'en ai fait une deuxième en
élargissant aux vidéastes culturel parce
que la science est un cas parmi d'autres
et donc là c'était de l'année dernière
il 190 répondants ma grande frustration
sur cèze enquête là c'est que comme on
n'a pas de liste exhaustive des
vidéastes c'est impossible de savoir à
quel point l'échantillon est
représentatif ou pas est-ce qu en ayant
190 répondants j'ai 80 % ou 10 % des
vidéastes existants j'en sais rien est
ce que mon panel démographique ou mon
panel
termes de nombre d'abonnés est
représentatif de la réalité de ce qu'il
ya sur youtube j'en sais rien non plus
donc je peux pas corrigé mes stats en
fonction de ça ça c'est la grosse
frustration et la limite principale du
travail je pense mais voilà du coup il
ya pas mal de trucs intéressants qui
sont ressortis comme on pense que les
filles ne sont pas présentes sur le
youtube culturel mais c'est faux il ya
quand même un tiers de femmes
on n'est pas à la moitié certes on est
en minorité mais un tiers c'est vraiment
pas négligeables comme proportions mais
c'est puisque la province ward et les
viewer 2 h est malheureusement plus
dramatique que beaucoup plus
malheureusement 6-6 donc les femmes sont
présentes sur youtube
donc si ça veut dire que si un déficit
de visibilité il vient pas du fait
qu'elle soit pas là et bien du fait
qu'elle soit pas regarder et là du coup
c'est d'autres questions qui se posent
ça confirme que dans le domaine de la
culture en général faire une chaîne
youtube c'est perdre de l'argent et que
les gens qui ont un bilan financier
positif pour la plupart c'est à peine
positif quoi c'est pas un moyen de
vraiment gagner sa vie en gros les gens
qui gagnent bien leur vie ça
représentait moins de 5% des modestes
et puis c'est les très grosses chaînes
voilà c'est nota bene dirty biology noz
man ce genre de truc de et c'est très
bien que ça existe mais c'est juste il
faut pas que les gens pensent que tout
le monde gagne sa vie en faisant une
chaîne youtube parce que c'est vraiment
pas le cas et ça confirme et que en fait
la population des vidéastes et est plus
précaire que la population générale
il y avait moins de gens en contrat de
travail que dans la population générale
et il y avait moins de cdi sur les gens
qui avaient des contrats de travail que
dans la population générale
donc faut être un peu dans la merde pour
faire une chaîne youtube
et voilà ça c'est un truc qui m'intrigue
et je ne sais pas comment l'évaluer de
laquelle dans quel sens ça se passe est
ce que c'est les gens qui ont du temps
libre qui se lance sur une chaîne
youtube et qui du coup
des situations professionnelles pas
stable ou est ce que c'est le fait
d'avoir une chaîne youtube qui fait
qu'on ne peut pas s'investir autant
qu'on voudrait dans un travail à côté et
je sais pas dans quel sens ça marche ça
me semble que ça un petit peu un peu
dans les deux sens
c'est pour quand on sent ce fait sur
youtube a aussi dit que je suis là et ça
c'est une question intéressante qui
oppose moi par exemple j'ai jamais vu ma
chaîne youtube comme un moyen de gagner
ma vie ou quoi que ce soit je fais ça
parce que je trouve que c'est
intéressant puis c'est tout mais il
n'empêche que je suis bien content
d'être à temps partiel parce que sinon
déjà même comme ça je n'arrive pas à
trouver le temps que je voudrais pour ma
chaîne mais si j'allais à temps plein je
pourrais pas clairement je pourrais pas
avec moi aussi j'ai demandé de contrats
y a un truc à 80 % seulement pour
dégager du temps pour faire des vidéos
aussi du coup là c'est la chaîne youtube
qui nous met dans une situation
professionnelle ou instables et de
choses qui t'ont surprise dans ses
études bah après c'était pas forcément
des surprises mais ça confirme des
intuitions que les vidéastes sont hyper
sollicitées et un peu quand on demande
il ya au moins la moitié des vidéastes
et sur un échantillon de 190 la moitié
ça fait déjà du monde qui ont été
sollicités pour faire des interventions
en tant que vidéaste c'est ça veut dire
que ça intéresse et qui a une certaine
reconnaissance du travail
après ça dépend des types
d'interventions un gars j'avais mis tout
un panel différent de dully aura
l'intervention télé à la conférence au
stand aux ateliers etc
mais globalement les vidéastes sont
sollicités par contre ils sont rarement
payé pour ça et c'est assez paradoxal
parce que ça veut dire qu'il ya une
reconnaissance du travail mais qui va
pas jusqu'à envisager de rémunérer les
gens pour ce travail là de sa bouche a
priori il ya une évolution sur les
dernières années les gens qui sont
sollicités depuis un moment sans une
évolution mais la reconnaissance
s'arrête
avant la rémunération ouais du coup toi
maintenant c'est quoi une politique
maintenant pour savoir quand est-ce que
tu demandes à être rémunéré j'essaye
mais le principe d'avoir des règles
c'est con mais des exceptions dedans
tout le temps en gros maintenant si ce
n'est pas rémunéré et que c'est pas que
j ai pas un intérêt personnel
j'y vais pas parce que j'ai pas le temps
simplement un chèque pas le temps après
j ça j'ai encore fait des trucs non
rémunéré il n'ya pas longtemps mais
parce que j'avais envie parce que
c'était avec des gens que j'avais envie
de voir parce que le contexte était
sympa mais j'essaye des mauvais parce
que l'emploi du temps craque de partout
et que déjà gardé un jour de repos dans
ma semaine c'est pas évident alors si en
plus je suis d' être que non rémunéré je
suis à 60 % quoi donc j'ai pas salaires
monstrueux le buzz de l'auto entreprise
etc
c'est quand même que ça devienne un peu
rentables financièrement donc et après
ça dépend aussi des structures qui me
contacte c'est sûr que si c'est une
petite association qui a pas beaucoup de
budget je peux pas demander le même
salaire que si c'est une grosse boîte ou
une grosse structure de recherche
tout ça c'est un peu à pondérer au cas
par cas mais j'essaye d'éviter de
travailler gratuitement au moins qu'il
ya un intérêt d'une façon ou d'une autre
je pense qu'on a un peu tous comme ça si
on va faire un projet qui n'est pas payé
c'est parce que ça nous intéresse de
toute façon parce qu'on en a parlé un
petit peu j'étais un il songe été un
événement avec tracks le kent dernier où
c'était que j'ai pas été rémunéré et
c'est très sympa et je pense que le fait
moi quand ces événements qui regroupe
pas mal de vidéastes aussi on est un peu
plus motivés parce qu'on sait qu'on va
avoir des amis
mais ça que font au niveau de transport
c'était quand même loin c'était horrible
c'était très sympa je remercie vraiment
les organisateurs mais ben ouais je me
dis on va repasser temps de transport
pour ça ça fait quand même beaucoup
beaucoup d'efforts donc je suis pas sûr
que je leur ferai mais du coup aussi on
a parlé entre villa c'était une
discussion assez intéressante soit sur
mac est ce parce que c'est un peu mieux
comme si on se coordonne un peu plus
sûres sur qu'est ce qu'on exige cancon
interview sollicité de la sorte
et ce avec moi je commence à demander de
plus en plus cher aux genevois de plus
en plus ça comme une contrainte bompas
et aussi parce que celui-ci de plus plus
qu'avant que c'est forcément sig et mes
petites secondes de réflexion que je me
fais c'est là qu'est ce que est ce que
j'ai passé un bon temps parce que si
c'est avec des gens sympas serait que ça
rajoute si c'est pour une bonne cause
c'est une petite association
ça rajoute c'est mieux que et du coup je
suis prête demandez moi c'est sécurisé
et j'avais donc peut-être penser à sa
jolie des gens sympas vous paierez moi
j'ai ouais ouais
en pratique en tout cas ça joue
indirects et après sinon maintenant je
sais pas si c'est une entreprise
clairement je demande d'autant plus cher
si ça m'apporte quelque chose aussi
parce que voici c'est l'occasion de
parler devant un public de gens
influents par exemple moi je suis prêt
demandé - du coup mais si c'est un
maintenant je suis dit un peu
publiquement comme ça ça peut être me
permettre de parce que je suis toujours
gêné de devoir refuser des sceaux
citations ou sais c'est pour la bonne
cause j'entends bien vraiment ça va être
pour la bonne cause ça me prend beaucoup
de temps et c'est fatigant et
mais il n'y a pas de honte à avoir
là-dessus je j'en ai discuté ya pas
longtemps dans s'il ya des gens qui
m'ont proposé un projet à qui j'ai dit
non parce que maintenant fait quand on
propose un projet très rapidement je
pose la question de ses coûts à votre
budget parce qu'en fait ça sert à rien
de passer une éternité discuter si à la
fin de toute façon ça va demander 40
heures de travail et que tout est
bénévole les jeux j'y vais pas je peux
pas me le permettre
et puis j'aimais pas forcément envie de
le faire parce que quelque part je
trouve que c'est un peu c'est un manque
de respect de se dire à cette personne
va travailler pour nous sans se dire ce
travail mérite salaire
il ya un truc qui me gêne un peu là
dedans
tiens on vient te chercher pour tes
compétences mais ses compétences la
mérite pas une rémunération due qu'à un
truc un peu paradoxal et du coup ce que
j'ai expliqué aux étudiants en question
c'est que bat pour que j'accepte un
projet il faut que je me retrouve d'une
façon ou d'une autre ça peut être
financier ça peut ne pas être financier
ça peut avoir accès un lieu de tournage
pouvoir rencontrer des personnes que
j'ai très envie de rencontrer mais s'il
ya aucune compensation d'aucune façon
pourquoi j'irais en fait que en effet
ces questions et après on est clairement
au delà de ça tu as tu mentionnait le
transport moi je sens le l'impact du
fait d'être à toulouse
parce que du coup pour rejoindre paris
depuis toulouse c'est super duke a pas
de tgv que c'est ou bien il faut prendre
l'avion et ça coûte un peu cher ou bien
il faut prendre le train et ça prend
plus d'une demi-journée et saputo aussi
assez cher on pratique l'avion et
parfois même moins cher que le train est
là ça me pose un problème moral parce
que dans l'absolu j'aimerais beaucoup de
moins prendre l'avion war ne plus
prendre l'avion mais en étant à toulouse
c'est compliqué et du coup il ya des
gens qui me proposent des projets ou
quand je demande juste que le transport
soit prêt en charge c'est pas possible
là clairement c'est un refus il ya un
truc que je ne fais plus et avancer de
l'argent enfin payer de ma poche
pour participer à un projet ça je peux
pas qu'en fait je peux pas me le
permettre
et puis vraiment ça me pose un problème
voir en gros maintenant ce genre de truc
à jojo je refuse que il ya peut-être le
seul cas où c'est vraiment un truc
d'altruisme et figueras nord où je
suivais de près fermons actions
altruistes
mais s'ils n'ont cessé puis il faut voir
même en termes de d'action ce comment
mon oiseau d'un peu en termes d'impact
aussi a le temps que je passe à donner
une conférence à préparer la conférence
à faire le transport c'est beaucoup de
temps que j'aurais pu dépenser à
travailler sur d'autres vidéos ou autre
chose qui aurait également un impact et
je prends soin maintenant tout ça en
compte
mais du coup je pense que tu vois très
bien pourquoi j'ai eu du mal à répondre
à ta question avec une règle franche et
nette à respecter c'est impossible il ya
beaucoup trop de paramètres c'est caron
mais en même temps je pense qu'il faut
pas qu'on ait honte de dire que c'est
normal qu'on soit payé pour travailler
il ya un espèce de tabous comme ça dans
la communauté des vulgarisateurs du web
parce que c'est pas que les vidéastes ou
bas comme on fait un travail qui est
déjà bénévole à la base pour produire du
contenu
c'est vrai que potentiellement on peut
être considéré comme des prestataires un
peu lokossou il n'y a pas besoin de
prévoir autant d'argent
et comme on parle pas d'argent entre
nous ce que culturellement c'est pas un
truc qui se fait beaucoup
ben on peut se faire avoir beaucoup plus
facilement qu'avant et puis il ya un peu
cette idée qu'on est un peu d ont fait
ça pour le bien commun promeut la
science pour la beauté la science ou
quelque chose comme ça et du coup il ya
un peu cette idée que notamment à
travers pas mal de l'association
les associations sont à but non lucratif
c'est le but c'est de faire tout le
monde aille mieux
et du coup l'argent est un peu tabou
dans ce mais si on veut se
professionnaliser vraiment avoir des
activités durables et vous même du bien
faire notre boulot c'est important en
fait d'avoir de penser à la rémunération
est de penser à quelque chose de plus
stable plus puis durable c'est ça parce
que je pense que les gens pas forcément
con conscience du côté instable de ce
que c'est parce que on peut entendre des
arguments du type oui mais tu as des
dons sur tipi etc
ça donne du confort ouais mais il est
donc sûr tipi ces bons suel il suffit
qu'il y ait un bad buzz sur n'importe
quoi et puis le mois d'après ya plus
rien même les gens qui ont des gros
revenus sur tipi peuvent pas considérer
ça comme une source de revenus stables
c'est pas possible
même les quand même les gros salaires
sur tipi sont pas enfin de plus en plus
si je vous ai été axé tout ça oui
au final cccc plus de l'échelle du smic
autre chose et c'est pendant injuste
minorités qui sont à l'échelle des semis
tu sais moi je suis à 60 euros par mois
70 euros clairement ça sert à payer le
logiciel d'augmenter en europe mais
c'est déjà super bien on peut à mine de
rien après parallèlement à tout le
raisonnement sûr on peut pas se
permettre de bosser gratuitement chaque
petit soutien à une vraie importance
parce que comme je disais la sphère des
vidéos ça coûte de l'argent
il ya plein de l'idéal ce qui sont
déficitaires et le simple fait de ne pas
perdre d'argent mais c'est déjà un grand
confort et ça pour le coup ça vient des
petits dons sur tipi qui permettent
d'amortir l'achat de matériel les frais
de déplacement etc
donc oui on a besoin de payer notre
loyer et ça se fera pas avec un euro
mais en même temps je pense qu'on sera
d'accord pour dire qu'on n'attend pas
que ce soit nos viewer qui n'ont pas une
employée et que chaque petit soutien
compte vraiment moi je sais que quand
j'ai un nouveau type
de un euro ça me fait plaisir c'est
parce que c'est une démarche active
d'aller faire un effort pour soutenir un
créateur etc
il ya l'aspect financier mais il ya
aussi l'aspect implications que ça
représente
donc je suis en situation un petit peu
différente
bah ça ça fait toujours plaisir quand on
me donne de l'argent sur tipi mais je
pense qu'on a d'autres qui ont plus
besoin de moi et moi c'est ces questions
un peu atypique parce que j'ai la chance
d'avoir un bon salaire je vis en suisse
je suis payée par l'université en suisse
mais je pense qu'il ya d'autres ont plus
besoin de cet argent n'est pas le seul à
avoir ce discours en si ça peut rassurer
je les ai déjà entendu de trois fois
sinon récemment il ya eu une discussion
autour de temps que kate a participé
voir et à initier au tour de l'adhésion
au café des sciences
bonjour c'est mon côté mettre les pieds
dans le plat
je pense que c'est un sujet important du
jeu c'est le moment de faire un petit
point qu'est ce que le café des sciences
vous avez entendu parler du café de sel
café café des sciences est une
association alors qu'il ya un peu plus
de dix ans maintenant mais je voudrais
pas dire de bêtises sur la dette qui à
la base avait été créée pour rassembler
des blogueurs scientifique pour créer
une communauté de blogueurs et pour
permettre de relire les scripts dès le
début ça avait cette double face au
double objectif de centraliser du
contenu pédagogique sur internet et
d'améliorer la qualité du contenu en
question
depuis ça a énormément grossi il ya un
certain pierre karner qui est passée par
là qui a créé la version pour les vidéos
la version pour les bd et récemment tout
art fusionner donc maintenant il ya le
café des sciences et au sein du café des
sciences on trouve des vidéos des
podcasts des blogs du dessin plein de
formats différents avec pour point
commun de partager du contenu
scientifique en prenant scientifique au
sens large puisqu'il a été votée qu'on
inclut est pas que les sciences dures
entre guillemets là dedans
et là dedans il ya l'idée que ce contenu
doit être fiable et pour ça il ya une
procédure d'évaluation c'est à dire que
pour rentrer au café des sciences po
candidate et il faut que la candidature
soit validé et cette validation passe
par une évaluation des gens qui sont
déjà membres de l'association qui vont
regarder les contenus et qui à partir
d'une liste de critères qui est public
dise ce contenu est approprié pour
rejoindre le café ce contenu n'est pas
approprié pour rejoindre le café c'est
celui pop au général sur le
fonctionnement du truck est le problème
et le problème c'est que ben on sait le
un problème récurrent des grosses
communautés c'est à dire que là on est à
peu près 200 personnes au café des
sciences et évaluer des contenus ça
prend énormément de temps
si on veut pouvoir s'exprimer de façon
fiable il faut aller regarder ou des
vidéos des articles de blog quel que
soit le support des fois les rangs
regardé plusieurs si c'est pas notre
domaine de compétence à la base ce qui
est quand même très souvent le cas parce
que les thématiques sont hyper varié à
fort potentiel m'en aller chercher des
sources vérifiées croisés et c'est donc
ça prend beaucoup de temps et le café
des sciences intéressant les gens il ya
beaucoup de candidatures a évalué à
chaque session d'évaluation et forcément
il ya un effet de commander un de
délégation on se dit c'est bon on est
nombreux les candidatures seront
évaluées du coup la proportion de
votants diminue ce que me disait alice
de la chaîne alice dans les étoiles qui
a regardé un peu des statistiques parce
qu'elle fait un mémoire là dessus c'est
que le nombre de votants est à peu près
stable alors que le nombre de cafetiers
augmente et diffusion de responsabilité
oui non mais c'est logique ainsi plus le
groupe est grand plus chacun pense que
le groupe va gérer sans avoir besoin de
s'en occuper individuellement c'est un
truc hyper naturel les sauf que du coup
ça ça pose vraiment une question qui est
de pour considérer le contenu comme
fiable il faut qu'ils aient été
approuvés par combien de personnes est
ce que est ce que le nombre de
validation est important ou pas et ça
lance ou tuent dans la collection sur
c'est quoi
un bon critères d'inclusion en fait est
ce qu'il vaut mieux que ça a été
regardée rapidement par 50 personnes ou
que ça a été évalué en détail par cinq
je ne sais pas de travail en ce moment
là dessus on va un peu se faisait le
cerveau mais ça soulève beaucoup de
questions intéressantes
ok du coup fois comme question on est
sur une communauté qui repose sur le
bénévolat
donc il ya une question de qu'est ce
qu'on peut imposer aux gens
est-ce qu'on peut obliger les gens à
évaluer des contenus et si oui à quelle
fréquence quelle quantité parce que le
but ce n'est pas que la communauté
redescendant non parce qu'on demande
trop de travail le but c'est juste que
l'étiquette de fiabilité associé à
l'association reste valide donc est-ce
qu'on peut obliger les gens à évaluer du
contenu ou pas c'est une vraie question
est ce que c'est vraiment le nombre
d'évaluations qui compte
ou est ce qu'il vaut mieux juste donner
les moyens aux gens d'évaluer plus dans
leur champ de compétence pour qu'ils
soient plus pertinent tant qu
évaluateurs et puis après il ya des
questions très pratiques de certaines
modifications demande un vote en
assemblée générale et doivent être
validées par tout le monde parce
qu'elles font changer les statuts de
l'association donc elles vont être plus
longue être mettre en place alors que
d'autres choses peuvent être juste des
éléments d'organisation pratique en
identifiant mieux les thématiques des
candidatures par exemple qui peuvent
être mises en place sans changement des
statuts donc qu'ils peuvent être mise en
place demain
mais voilà donc il ya une réflexion sur
le court terme et long terme en ayant en
tête que dans tout le monde fait ça
bénévolement et qu'on peut pas reprocher
aux gens de ne pas s'impliquer plus le
fond mais qu'il faut pas que la
crédibilité du contenu en pâtissent non
plus c'est une problématique serait très
difficile
tu peux qui leader n'est pas sans
rappeler le principe des pires review du
peer review recherche que c'est
exactement l'idée
c'est exactement le même problème parce
que si on veut arriver une décision
finalement et est en fait c'est très
complexe quoi et monde de main d'oeuvre
et puis les gens sont pas payés pour le
faire je me sens simplement la recherche
dans le pierre review je pense ya encore
un aspect un peu plus compliqué cet
outil et conflits d'intérêts oui oulala
au café des sciences
on n'est pas sur un milieu où les gens
sont en concurrence les uns avec les
autres
alors que moi je sais que dans mon
domaine de recherche qui était un
domaine plutôt bien financées il y avait
une énorme compétition entre les gens et
que par exemple quand on envoyait un
papier à un journal en général on
pouvait préciser une liste de noms dont
on ne voulait pas qu'il fasse partie des
railleries beurre parce qu'on voulait
pas qu'ils aient accès aux données non
publiées
ça c'est un tout un aspect encore plus
compliqué de copinage c'est malheureux
mais qui existe à propre image inc a
quand même aussi des pointes de copinage
bon c'est pas la même échelle que vécut
la recherche sans but mais entre vie est
un acquis qui se connaissent que
forcément
et c'est pas notre truc c'est que c'est
pas si évident de parce que papa pas
quelqu'un qui va parler de maths qui a
fait 17 science font n'importe quel
sujet il ya différents niveaux de
rigueur c'est pas juste juste ou pas
juste technique ce tour nous c'est
souvent beaucoup plus nuancée que ça etc
c'est pas facile fonds n'a peut-être pas
tout ce même curseur de dire quand est
ce que c'est suffisamment rigoureux pour
être au café et puis il ya un peu aussi
s'attiser enfin parce qu'il ya aussi des
contenus qui sont au sein du café ils
n'étaient origines et des loyers enfin
bon je pense aux contenus de stéphane
ont escorté les présidents du réseau
monuc se sont creusés mais bayer avant
un effort de deux musées source de
relecture par par des chercheurs il ya
vraiment un effort de rigueur qui est
qu'on ne retrouve pas forcément chez
tous les vidéastes du café des sciences
et du cou enfin il ya peu se prennent
que bon bah si on accepte du contenu qui
est de moins bonne qualité
- une bonne rigueur on va dire ça peut
ternir un petit peu l'image du café de
bâle et du coup en particulier de
l'image des vidéos de stephen alors
l'impact des critères d'évaluation sur
la reconnaissance du contenu produit par
le président non mais c'est une question
récurrente dans la vulgarisation
c'est vulgariser d'une façon ou d'une
autre même si je déteste le dire ça
revient à simplifier mais est simplifié
ça peut simplement être changés du
vocabulaire pour rendre les mots plus
compréhensive roues ça peut être
simplifié les idées passé sous silence
des exceptions etc il ya des façons de
le faire qu'ils sont plus ou moins
rigoureuse je sais que personnellement
le conditionnel est mon ami mais mais il
ya des gens qui n'aiment pas ça parce
que ça donne l'impression que tout est
flou et on sait pas trop à quoi se fier
et c'est pas forcément une bonne
représentation non plus on va pas parler
de bail et ziani semer du curseur de
voila tu vois très bien ce que j'ai en
tête et je pense que ton public il faut
a très bien ce que jean
mais voilà donc donner la sensation que
rien n'est certain c'est aussi un peu
dangereux parce qu'en fait c'est pas
parce qu'on notre certitude n'est pas à
100% que c'est pas une certitude mais
voilà il ya toujours des vraies
questions de où on place le curseur et
je pense que c'est très personnel et
même pour un même producteur de contenu
moi je sais que sur mes différents
formats j'ai pas du tout le même curseur
j'ai commencé avec un format de biologie
moléculaire ou là j'ai essayé d'être
vraiment hyper rigoureuse en gros je
plaçais le critère de rigueur à peu près
au niveau de mes cours de prépa
installions n'est pas forcément à la
pointe du truc avec toutes les
précautions d'usagé mais on est quand
même sur du savoir bien établie et
expliquer à ces en profondeur et puis
plus tard j'ai lancé un format qui l'a
bien plus de mon quotidien de médiatrice
qui consiste à présenter des petites
expériences un pas facile à refaire à la
maison
et là l'objectif du format c'est que les
gens trouvent les expériences sympa et
les refasse pas de les noyer sous les
explications et du coup sur ce format là
les explications de trucs hyper
compliqué à base de tension de surface
etc doivent tenir en 30 secondes
et forcément ça oblige à fermer des
choix drastiques de simplification de
vocabulaire etc et j'essaye toujours
d'avoir des formules qui rende clair que
c'est une simplification parfois un peu
abusive et je mets des liens dans la
description etc
mais quand j'écris j'ai bien conscience
que mes curseur n'ont rien à voir
et en même temps j'ai la sensation que
les deux contenus sont légitimes pour
une structure comme le café des sciences
qui a pour but de produire du contenu
fiable mais aussi d'attirer les gens
vers le contenu scientifique alors que
si on accepte que du contenu hyper
exigeants le public va forcément se
réduire et ce serait dommage c'est ce
qui expliquait aussi david
sur twitter où dans une interview avec
ap sol où il ya les envoya un peu deux
objectifs qu'on nous donne quoi être
être accessible et être rigoureux et on
peut pas s'allier à un compromis à
trouver on peut pas être à fond sur les
deux fait quelque part sur les deux et
puis même en temps de production bien je
sais que vidéo où je simplifie les
explications une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai lancé ce format c'est
que ça me prenait beaucoup moins de
temps que les vidéos où je vais passer
trente heures juste sur la biblio c'est
sûr que c'est sais pas il contraint
cofely les podcasts sont les interviews
comme ça c'est beaucoup moins préparés
c'est l'occasion de ces c'est beaucoup
moins coûteux en temps mais énergie à
faire une fois ça dure trois heures ça
ne dure que trois heures de préparation
à part de tournage comme ça c'est un peu
ça l'objectif que c est que très peu de
temps et je trouve que c'est très
important en fait que quelques ça dure
parce qu'en fait je pense qu'on apprend
beaucoup par répétition dans ce monde
baignant dans le domaine peut même
essayer des bêtises qui sont dites
et puis même dans mes vidéos sérieuse 30
ans noyé jeudi
j'ai dit une énorme bêtise donc c'est
très coûteux d'enlever toutes les
bêtises ça prend un temps
essentiellement ses traits poteau puis
comme tu dis c'est impossible de réussir
à 100%
moi ya des trucs que j'ai dit dans mes
premières vidéos qui à l'époque n'était
pas des bêtises et qui maintenant en
sont par exemple donc des fois tu fais
tout bien et puis en fait l'état de la
recherche avancée par exemple il ya une
affirmation que j'avais entendu en cours
à l'époque comme quoi où il y aurait dix
fois plus de bactéries que de cellules
humaines dans un corps humain et c'est
hyper marquants comme comme chiffres et
sauf que c'est un chiffre qui est très
vieux et que estimé le nombre de
bactéries dans un corps humain et
estimait le nombre de cellules humaines
dans un corps humain
c'est très compliqué et une publication
est sorti il ya quelques années qui
disait que ce chiffre-là et
vraisemblablement faux et que on est
plus de l'ordre de grandeur de autant de
bactéries que de cellules humaines
et voilà et il ya souvent des choses
comme ça qui change dans le domaine de
la microbiologie ou la biologie
cellulaire on a des outils qui évolue
très vite donc on a des connaissances
qui évolue très vite et même si on était
parfait et qu'on n'ait jamais d'erreur
basques ont dit peut devenir obsolète
six mois plus tard et ça c'est à mon
avis un des gros problèmes de youtube
c'est l'absence de possibilité de
corriger
ouais par des avec vivienne c'est un
vrai problème
fils de course des as qui disait à
youtube et tu cognes aujean de youtube
que enfin qui est quasi en train de
supplier de leur permettre de loreo
claude d'une vidéo d'une nouvelle
version en fait d'une vidéo les deux
versions structures disponibles pour
voir si les gens veulent accéder à
l'ancienne version
mais avoir quand même c'est cette
nouvelle version qui permet de corriger
puis d'éviter que un réseau club complet
parce qu'un repli au complet on perde
l'url non par les commentaires ont
partout et puis en plus ça fait une
notification puces pour les gens
[Musique]
s'envoient imaginer plein d'outils
pratiques genre simplement pouvoir
rajouter une image en début de vidéo
elle pourrait être modifiables et sur
cette image on fait un erratum où on
précise qu'un erratum à les consulter
dans la description c'est pas un travail
technique monstrueux je pense et ça
aiderait voilà j'étais un peu dégoûté
parce que j'utilisais les annotations
comme tout le monde je pense pour pour
corriger et du coup sûr mais première
vidéo il y en avait quelques unes et
youtube a supprimé les annotations c'est
à dire qu'on ne pouvait plus en rajouter
mais maintenant les anciennes ont
disparu mais correctifs ont disparu et
ça me rend malade
du coup il ya cette vidéo je dis que 39
et dans un nombre premier la notation
pour dire qu'en fait messi se trouvait
ces résultats après ça fait aussi
relativiser dans le sens où comme en est
un c'est normal qu'ils puissent y avoir
des erreurs dans des vidéos et c'est
important de toujours les regarder avec
esprit critique et de rester vigilant
je pense que c'est un message pour
trouve très très souvent chez les
vulgarisateurs du web en particulier
parce qu'on a des supports fixes quoi
mais même les médiateurs qui anime des
ateliers sur le terrain de rester
vigilant je sais que à l'endroit où j'ai
travaillé au tout début il y avait un
gros travail qui a été fait sur ça et il
ya une conférence expérimental sur la
chaîne 2 le s p g qui est trouvable sur
internet que je trouve super passifs ont
plein d'expérience hyper démonstrative
et au milieu des expériences il y en a
une qui est une entourloupe
c'est à dire qu'ils font l'expérience
comme si c'était un truc comme les
autres quoi sauf qu'en fait ils mentent
aux gens il ya un cachet à un moment et
il demande aux gens de proposer des
explications mais les gens se creuse la
tête et la conclusion du truc c'est ben
en fait on est juste en train de vous
mentir parce que rien ne nous empêche de
vous mentir et là on le fait
volontairement bon pourrait le faire
sans que ce soit volontaire et de
réveiller un petit coup de boost comme
ça gardez votre esprit critique même si
la personne qui vous parle est
compétente et maîtrise son sujet vous
n'êtes jamais à l'abri d'une erreur et
j'avais trouvé l'idée merveilleuse eu
l'aval belge passé récemment à la radio
suisse oui ou parler enfin c'était le
sujet c'était les médias en général en
particulier le vernis scientifique et il
ya une petite partie où je me parler de
youtube et de la veille dit est en haut
de ce qui est dit sur youtube
wen a profité pour critiquer tout le
monde je vais dire que la validité du
contenu en général toutes les échelles
en fait c'est un problème difficile puis
même au niveau de la duplication
scientifique ya un truc à prendre avec
des pincettes c'est souvent le corpus
scientifique est beaucoup plus fiable
que la dernière publication scientifique
et vous faire gaffe à tout ça et c'est
pas facile c'est pas facile et un
certificat lé vrai ou faux après c'est
un truc ça pour le coup c'est quelque
chose qui me restera je pense toute ma
vie de mon expérience de recherche c'est
que quand on fait de la recherche on est
obligé de passer par un processus mental
qui nous fait prendre conscience que
rien n'est jamais complètement certain
et ça implique une certaine modestie
d'être prêt à remettre en cause le truc
sur lequel on travaille depuis des
années
si il ya des arguments suffisants qui
viennent nous remettre en cause et c'est
pas si évident que ça parce qu'on a beau
le dire c'est une chose et le faire et
elle vraiment prêt à se remettre en
cause si on nous prouve qu'on a tort en
fait c'est hyper difficile et c'est
assez lié à toutes ces questions de
d'esprit critique je trouve dans le sens
où ça implique une modestie vis-à-vis de
la connaissance d'avoir l'idée que les
curseurs ne sont jamais à 100% et nos
curseur doivent rester mobile tout le
temps et ça implique aussi nos curseur
de confiance en un interlocuteur données
même le plus brillant peu d'entre nous
peut dire parfois des petites bêtises
cécile après il ya un truc rigolo là
dessus et je te rejoins sur ce que tu
disais je systématiquement quand je suis
invité à intervenir autour de la
vulgarisation sur internet et sur
youtube il ya quelqu'un à un moment ou
un autre qui fait remarquer que quand
même on peut pas trop se confier au
contenu scientifique sur internet parce
qu'il ya un peu tout et n'importe quoi
et c'est une remarque qui est vrai mais
je trouve ça assez sidérant que dans la
tête des gens se soient si fortement
associée à internet
2 en général quand on dit ça je réponds
oui effectivement il ya du bon et du
mauvais sur youtube mais je vous
rappelle qu'à la télévision l'histoire
est incarnée par lorànt deutsch et
stéphane bern peut-être que c'est
questionnable aussi en terme de rigueur
mais c'est vrai c'est à dire que sur la
télévision publique et à la radio
publique on entend tout et n'importe
quoi sur le plan scientifique aussi et
ça ça a l'air d'interpeller personne
mais il sait gré les jo j'ai pas osé le
dire pendant l'interview est aujourd'hui
pardon plus geoffrey beaucoup plus
confiance aux vidéos de de david et
stéphane que ce qui sort dans un journal
scientifique pas là par exemple j'ai eu
le livre de harari sapiens une histoire
de l'humanité il n'ya pas longtemps ce
qu'on me l'avait offert il ya des choses
qui m'ont interpellé et du coup je suis
allé demander l'avis de stéphane parce
que j'ai beaucoup plus confiance en
stéphane et hans qui va me répondre
en connaissant le domaine que dans
l'auteur de ce livre que je ne connais
pas et c'est pas parce qu'il a écrit un
livre que c'est nécessairement fiable en
fait je pense qu'on a dit suffisamment
devient de ce fait ne rejette pas du
qu'il a fait c'est bon président
c'est validé ouais et après il ya un
autre truc que je trouve important parce
que par rapport à ces histoires de
fiabilité des vidéos
c'est le positionnement des profs parce
que j'avais fait une intervention pour
des enseignants pour leur donner des
conseils pour utiliser des ressources
vidéo dans leur classe et ça les
préoccupent et énormément d'être sûr de
projeter quelque chose de fiable
ce que je peux comprendre loi pendant
enseignante a envie que le contenu que
tu délivres à tes élèves soient hyper
rigoureux et qui ait pas de mauvaises
idées qui se diffuse et en fait gérés
passé un certain temps à essayer de leur
faire intégrer le fait que ce n'était
pas grave s'il y avait des erreurs et en
y réfléchissant je pense que si j'étais
prof je diffuserai volontairement des
vidéos avec des erreurs à mes élèves et
à la fin du visionnage
je leur dirai bah ouais dans cette vidéo
il ya trois erreurs énormes l'écrit
parce que je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant en fait pour les
éduquer à l'esprit critique de leur
diffuser du contenu avec des erreurs et
de chercher les erreurs avec eux que de
chercher toujours du contenu
irréprochable et je me suis fait la
réflexion que dans toute ma scolarité on
m'avait toujours présente et que du
contenu est irréprochable et en fait
c'est très dommage on a peut-être que
même le contenu nous enseigne le bon y'a
bon en maths ira jusqu'au lycée en fait
il ya moins de pour un point mais qu un
puriste ya toujours moyen d de dirhams
et c'est pas si compliqué que ça c'était
il ya besoin de plus de critiques
je sais qu'à l'époque on apprenait la
bio à l'école on parle beaucoup de ce
qui était vivipare ovipare reptiles
enfin tous ces maux qui sont pas très
phylogénétique veut dire à juste la
notion d'espèce en fait relativement mal
expliqué tout
peut-être même qu'il faut faire
peut-être preuve de plus de critiques de
ceux qui ont été et qui est dans les
livres de colorcon après ça s'inscrit
non tout une démarche pédagogique dans
le sens on s'y ajuste un prof quitté ça
je sais pas quel impact ça aurait sur
les élèves s'ils se diraient juste bon
se profile quand même un peu chelou ou
aussi ses influents serait vraiment leur
façon de penser ce que des fois il
suffit d'en profs pour te retourner la
tête et que tu vois le monde
différemment ça arrive mais c'est pas
facile à accepter l'incertitude et la
remise en question pas moi ça m'a pris
un certain temps quand j'ai commencé à
faire de la recherche à sortir de l'idée
que si ça avait été prouvée c'était
acquis une bonne fois pour toutes
c'est pas facile c'est aussi cette
tendance notamment en mathématiques en
tout cas considérer que ce qu'on nous
apprend c'est voir une la bonne façon de
faire c'est la seule façon de faire et
on va alors qu'en fait théorie des
ensembles c'est une façon de faire des
maths
il ya d'autre que du coup via
l'enseignement peut-être avant le fait
que peut-être qu'on a désiré
interrogations on est censé un peu
recracher le court
et puis il ya vraiment la seule façon
dans la façon à faire de faire très
classique qui fait qu'on a tendance du
coup à donner trop d'importance à ça et
à ces risques seule façon de faire mais
c'est très difficile de danser dès cette
modestie épistémique après c'est marrant
parce que moi les maths c'est vraiment
la matière où j'ai le plus souvent eu
cette sensation de découvrir un truc
nouveau et qu'on m'avait menti avant je
sais pas comment le fond voient qu'on
peut apprendre à compter au début c'est
1 2 3 4 puis on explique qu'il ya des
nombres négative puis qu'il ya des
virgules
puis il ya des complexes et mine de rien
c'est une bonne illustration de comment
partir d'un truc très simplifié et a
rajouté des petits bouts de complexité
et italie
ils sont chez but tu t y retrouver tweet
suivant leur fait qu'est ce qui était
encore faire c'était tu t'es sur une
publication qui a départagé par le café
des sciences donc le café des sciences
avait automatiquement partager
quelque chose et beaucoup de gens
s'étaient plaints de la validité
scientifique de ce qui avait été
partagée par le café des sciences en
effet bah ça c'est intéressant parce que
comme on disait il ya une procédure
d'évaluation au départ et une fois que
les gens sont membres du café des
sciences le partage des contenus et
automatisés on peut choisir de partager
tout son contenu ou juste une partie en
mettant des mots clés mais le conte
partager automatisé parce que c'est pas
gérable de partager manuellement sur
plusieurs réseaux sociaux et sur le site
le contenu de deux cents personnes
et du coup c'est très important d'avoir
un système d'alarmé a posteriori ce que
quelqu'un peut avoir fait que des trucs
très bien et puis d'un coup vrillé
complètement c'est arrivé plusieurs fois
déjà
ces noces man qui avait fait un bref au
sur l'adn qui était bourré d'erreurs
factuelles et quand on lui a dit il a
supprimé et il a refait une vidéo en
travaillant avec un biologiste pierre en
l'occurrence pour s'assurer que ce soit
hyper fiable
donc c'est un système qui fonctionne
bien et qui au café des sciences
fonctionne à la fois sur les réseaux
publics placer des gens sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ont interpellé mais qui peut
aussi fonctionner en interne on a déjà
eu des échanges de mails pour dire oui
moi ce contenu il est quand même un peu
limite
il faudrait qu'on fasse un truc donc
c'est important pour le côté fiabilité
mais c'est aussi très important de
garder en tête que tout ça et du
bénévolat et que la bienveillance et la
moindre des choses et c'était un peu le
ce à quoi je voulais arriver avec mes
nombreux tweets d'hier c'est que on peut
faire remonter qu'un contenu est
problématique et que ça paraît pas
normal qu'ils soient partagés par telle
structure etc
mais il ya plusieurs façons de le dire
et là en l'occurrence moi j'ai été assez
surprise par le ton des remarques et le
fait que alors moi du coup j'ai pas vu
la première version de l'article met
donc à priori la première version était
vraiment problématique dans le sens où
elle est
et militante plus que scientifique et la
version que moi j'ai vu c'était devenu
un article de botanique
je suis pas botaniste donc je peux pas
évaluer la pertinence du contenu mais ça
m'a pas l'air alarmant un article de
botanique en soi et il ya des gens qui
ont continué à critiquer après que cette
version soit sorti et qui clairement
critiqué jusque sur le titre parce que
le titre faisait appel à la pétition sur
les coquelicots etc et est en fait c'est
juste une version blog du pit à creek
habituel des vidéastes clairement de
mettre un titre un peu provocateur pour
la au final avoir un article de
botanique
c'est un procédé qu'on connaît tous
assez bien et voilà et le fait qu'il y
ait des gens qui continuent à critiquer
manifestement sans avoir lu l'article
déjà je trouvais que c'était assez
gênant parce que ça veut dire que eux
ils ont pris cinq secondes pour lire un
titre et derrière ça déclenche des
heures de travail parce que dans le café
des sciences fait les choses
sérieusement quoi donc quand il ya eu
les signalements il ya le bureau qui
s'est mobilisé pour trouver des
relecteurs pour échanger avec la
personne qui a écrit l'article
parce que le but c'est aussi de rester
bienveillant auprès de l'auteur ait pas
de l'agresser en dix ans d'un pouvoir
est ton contenu n'était pas assez bien
le but ce n'est pas de faire fuir les
gens au contraire c'est de les aider à
améliorer leur contenu donc il ya toute
une notion de pédagogie et de
bienveillance là derrière et tout ça a
fait que j'ai quand même eu envie
d'écrire un thread de mon côté là dessus
parce que ça me paraissait important de
le dire et parce que je me suis aussi
dit que ça soulagerait un peu le bureau
de ne pas avoir que des messages
négatifs dans cette journée qui a été un
peu difficile est de pouvoir rediriger
vers les tweets de quelqu'un d'autre
au lieu de refaire eux mêmes les
explications à chaque fois parce que la
journée a quand même commencé pour eux
avec énormément de copier coller pour
expliquer que le partage les contenus
est automatique je pense qu'ils ont
passé un lundi bien compliqué à gérer le
problème est qu'ils s'en sont hyper bien
sorti parce que au final la version qui
en ligne de l'article a été corrigé
la personne qui a écrit l'article a eu
des échanges hyper constructif ena
du tout était bon risqués ou quoi que ce
soit et c'est rassurant que le système
d'alarmé fonctionne mais si les gens
pouvaient faire les remarques de façon
polie et constructives plutôt que à base
de c'est quoi cette histoire
ce serait plus agréable pour tout le
monde bien ouais parce que c'est rare
mais ça je vois que je que j'aime bien
partager c'est i et ii il faut plus de
bienveillance et soyons davantage
bienveillant et c'est de voir qu'est-ce
qui peut être mieux fait et qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui est ce mieux comprendre un
peu les choses avant de critiquer à tout
va
est ce qu'aujourd'hui le café est devenu
un très gros truc est beaucoup beaucoup
de gens c'est difficile de tout
surveiller
c'est compliqué et il faut faut du temps
de la bienveillance et soit aussi pas
mal de temps de travail l'état pas de
pas mal de gens donc qu'ils soient en
pis bénévoles ouais plus de
bienveillance ac c'est souhaitable et je
crois que ma conclusion à la fin c'était
que en plus de ça c'est toujours pas mal
de prendre le temps de dire aux gens
qu'on apprécie leur travail quand ils
font bien
au lieu de juste se manifester pour
critiquer quand ya un souci ça aide
quand même pour repartir parce que quand
on se mange toute une série de critiques
d'un coup alors qu'on n'a pas forcément
le contrepoids positive quand tout va
bien ça doit pas toujours être évident
de repartir
et puis même lorsqu'on critique
je ne sais pas comment le bureau du café
a dû qu'aux critiques et de la personne
qui tenait ce blog mais j'imagine pas
mal de bergues ayant compris dans la
critique est ce que si si le but
finalement c'est que le levier du
contenu de qualité qui soit partagé par
le café faire preuve de bienveillance et
sont une bonne façon d'y arriver c'est
sûr pas si quand quelqu'un produit un
contenu qui est pas assez solide
la réaction c'est de le critiquer
brutalement et qui sortent du café mais
continue à publier son contenu ailleurs
au final l'objectif d'améliorer la
fiabilité du contenu produit sur
internet il n'est pas du tout atteint et
c'est vraiment dommage si on est ce que
quand tu vois le futur de la
vulgarisation ce que tu penses que on va
voir des boulots plus mot précaire à
l'avenir ça c'est une grande question
il ya une différence entre les
intentions et les moyens quand je
regarde les rapports qui sont remis
parce qu'il ya des stratégies nationales
de la culture scientifique etc
il ya beaucoup de travail qui est fait
là dessus au niveau des institutions en
france
en tout cas après je je connais pas trop
la situation ailleurs vu que tu restes
en france les intentions sont hyper
bonne il ya toute une réflexion
notamment sur le fait de comment mieux
impliquer les chercheurs etc etc de
construire des nouveaux projets de
s'emparer des nouveaux médias d'aller
construire des tiers lieux pour aller
chercher du public qui sent pas font ça
forcément concerné à la base après moi
ça me gêne toujours un peu que dans ces
beaux rapports d'intention il ya aucun
élément financier ou au concret de ce
que on est dans une période global de
restrictions budgétaires
il n'y a pas beaucoup de budget pour la
science en tant que tel pour la
recherche pour l'enseignement
ça paraît logique qui est pas forcément
beaucoup de budget pour la culture
scientifique non plus c'est peut-être
une erreur
à titre personnel je pense que c'est une
erreur parce que l'esprit critique ça va
bien au delà de la science
c'est pour moi une question de
citoyenneté général en même temps
l'enseignement ça rentre aussi un peu
dans cette catégorie là et c'est pas
spécialement bien pis non c'est non plus
voilà je pense que ça risque d'être un
peu compliqué dans les années qui
arrivent dans le sens où les intentions
sont très bonnes mais si les moyens sont
pas mis en oeuvre les projets verront
peut-être le jour mais ils verront le
jour avec des personnels qui resteront
globalement précaire après la précarité
elle est aussi lié à un truc qui est
qu'il ya beaucoup de petites structures
de médiation et ça c'est très chouette
parce que en même temps si l'âme et la
vulgarisation en france était faite que
par des grosses structures avec des
fonctionnaires en cdi qui reste toute
leur vie il y aura un problème de de
dynamisme et d'innovation pour et
semblablement et sait très bien qui est
plein de petites associations qui fasse
des trucs à droite à gauche qui ont du
coup pas forcément les moyens
d'embaucher quelqu'un à temps plein ou
en cdi mais qui apporte un énorme
dynamisme aux actions de vulgarisation
la précarité est bien aussi de ça
quelque part et permet plus de liberté
aussi devenir culte moi je pense qu on
approche de la fin je passais d'autres
choses que tu aimerais rajouter là pas
trop je pense qu'on a parlé de à peu
près tous les traits coup j'ai des
choses à dire
du coup quel est le message qui est
qu'elle est qu'elle serait un message
clé que tu aimerais que les auditeurs
retiennent de cette interview aulas
j'étais pas préparé pour ça non mais tu
vois par rapport à tout ce qu'on a
discuté je pense que si les gens
retiennent juste le message de la
bienveillance c'est peut-être le plus
important parce que c'est celui qui
s'applique aux plus de domaines concrets
de la vie quotidienne de chacun c'est
pas parce qu'on critique quelqu'un qu'on
peut se permettre de critiquer n'importe
comment
et le fait d'être bienveillant sera de
toute façon toujours beaucoup plus
productif que d'être agressif
cool je suis d'accord je ne veux pas
voir critiquer ça est ce que tu vas
finir avec deux recommandations ou plus
les gens font
deux vidéos podcasts livres ou personnes
à suivre
alors qui ne concerne pas une des
cinquante personnes
on a déjà mentionné plein de fois alors
tu restes le café vaut mieux cité
stefanski non pour les gens qui sont
intéressés par la biologie jour il ya
plein de chaînes qui parle de biologie
sur youtube et connaissez sans doute
déjà mais il ya deux chaînes qui sont à
mon avis pas du tout assez connue par
rapport à la qualité du travail fourni
c'est la chaîne de la blouse qui est
technicien de recherche et qui fait des
vidéos vraiment chouette et de petite
gêne ce sont deux chaînes du café des
sciences jeu j'assume mon conflit
d'intérêts mais le sugen qui faisait
aussi de la recherche jusqu'à n'y a pas
très longtemps et qui fait de la
biologie cellulaire et moléculaire qui
abordent des thématiques assez proche de
celle que moi je peux aborder
donc c'est ce type de contenu vous
intéresse ça vaut vraiment coup d'aller
voir ces deux chaînes là et après pour
contrebalancer un peu la critique que
j'ai pu faire tout à l'heure du
traitement de l'assurance dans les
grands médias
je pense que je ne vais pas le faire
découvrir aux gens mais je recommande
quand même chaudement la méthode
scientifique qui est une émission de
france culture dont la qualité du
contenu est à mon avis vraiment très
très élevé et qui en plus a fait
l'effort et c'est les seuls à mon avis
qu'ils ont fait de cette façon-là de
s'ouvrir aux bulgarie thater du web et
de vraiment placer les vulgarisateurs du
web qu'ils invitent sur un pied
d'égalité par rapport à des journalistes
scientifiques ou d'autres intervenants
de ce type et délais je tiens à les
remercier pour ça c'est une
reconnaissance de notre travail qui est
vraiment pas négligeable il associe
souvent la parole à des jeunes
chercheurs je pense que c'est une des
rares émissions que j'ai vu invité en
invité unique une doctorante par exemple
pour une émission d'une heure voilà et
cette approche-là hyper ouverte d'esprit
est associé à une rigueur de travail et
une qualité de réalisation vraiment top
donc si vous ne connaissez pas ce
podcast vraiment aller voir ça vaut le
coup merci
je plussoie est alors étant moi-même
fans de nicolas martin qu'on aime bien
été invité sur twitter merci beaucoup en
tout cas d'avoir accepté cette
invitation et pour les éditeurs à penser
à faire des trucs classiques elle a
quelques montées tout ça et je vous dis
à une prochaine fois probablement tuyaux
fallu